Das war's für heute.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Die
Ok, moin leute, schön dass ihr wieder am Start seid, wir spielen heute noch mal ein paar
Runden, das beste Battlefield aller Zeiten, Battlefield 2042, nein das ist kein Sponsort
Stream, wenn es Sponsort Stream wäre, dann würde das im Titel stehen, oder haben sich
ja heute auf YouTube manche beschwert, das würde so fake wirken, ich mein es war Sponsort,
was soll ich sagen, ich mein mal ernsthaft leute, jetzt mal ernsthaft, weiß ich, weiß
ich ob ihr das Video heute gesehen habt, übrigens, das Bild ist immer noch falsch, was ihr angezeigt
wird zu mir, das ist der Fabian und bin ich ich, egal, der Day One Patch, der Day One Patch
hat alles, komplett alles gefixt, die haben auch die Maps ausgetauscht, es sind jetzt
sieben gute Maps dabei, Leute haben sich heute teilweise beschwert, so nach dem Motto, hier
irgendwie in Richtung, keine Ahnung, Sponsoren, oder hier, sowas hier in der Richtung, ja,
Max tut mir leid, aber das Video wirkt fake, ja mein Gott, was soll ich denn machen, soll
ich erstmal in einem Sponsort Video hingehen und sagen, so Leute, Video ist Sponsort bei
ihr, und als erstes gucken wir uns jetzt mal die Liste mit den 5000 Bucks auf Reddit an,
also wie stellt ihr sich das vor, wie soll das funktionieren, klappt doch nicht, übrigens
Leute, ich muss mein Streaming Setup unbedingt mal verbessern, also, oh, oh, so, richtig
broken hier, null, aber ich muss unbedingt ein ordentliches Mikrofon kaufen, also ein,
nein, das stimmt nicht, ich habe ja ein ordentliches Mikrofon, ich brauche unbedingt ein Mikrofon,
dass ich so einstellen kann, dass es das Geklapper von der Tastatur nicht aufnimmt, aber, dass
sich besser anhört, ich habe ja heute ein Video gemacht, hier ein Video mit meinem Headset,
das hört sich einfach nicht so gut an, Headset hört sich einfach, also das geht besser,
das geht besser, Moin, Battlefield 015, ja, das ist halt, es ist einfach mitten aus der
Entwicklung gerissen, übrigens, das Video, was ich euch gestern gezeigt habe, wo ich
so ein bisschen vom Leder gezogen, heißt das, wo ich ein bisschen abgelästert habe, Battlefield,
ich habe das nochmal etwas seriöser neu aufgenommen und bisschen, bisschen, bisschen besser auch
das alles begründet, wenn sich da jetzt noch einer aufregt oder in seiner Fanboy-Äre verletzt
fühlt, dann weiß ich auch nicht mehr, keine Ahnung, no plan, overly, moin, ja, aber sowas
von, so, ich würde sagen, starten wir schon mal, es sind ja alle drin, hier sechs Leute
am Start, was ist denn los, Captain Peng, willst du mitspielen, falls du da bist, weiß
ich nicht, mal gucken, ich invitee ihn gleich einfach, Captain Poggers, dachte das verdammte
Spiel, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, moin Leute, jetzt kommen sie aber hier, zwei Drittel,
wo ist das erste Drittel hin, da fehlt was, du kannst nicht, warum nicht, ah, du bist
nicht daheim, verstehe, verstehe, möb, danke für den Club, oh hier Rare, Rare Twitch Turbo,
hat auch keiner mehr eingeplant, ich weiß, kann man immer noch kaufen, hat kaum noch
einer eingeplant, richtig, richtig oldschool, vibes hier, wisst ihr was mir gerade aufgefallen
ist, die Spezialistin mit dem Wingsuit, also die hier, Collection, die da, die hier, die
kommt doch aus Frankreich, ist das ein französisches Wort, Sundance klingt irgendwie nicht sonderlich
französisch oder ist das Sordans oder irgendwie sowas, keine Ahnung, klingt nicht, klingt
nicht französisch, aber die redet französisch und sie ist auf dem Profil, auf diesem Profil,
Spezialist Profil, ist das nicht französisch, warum ist das nicht französisch, weil hier
Poggers, Alter, auch mal gucken, ob das wieder mal ein Settings verkackt hat, Battlefield,
was ist los mit dir, ich verstehe nicht, ich verstehe nicht, warum dieses Game sich immer
wieder, ich verstehe nicht, warum dieses Game sich immer wieder umstellt, wo ist denn da
der Sinn, die restlichen Einstellungen sind ja gleich hier, guck, die Controller Settings
sind, also ich spiele nicht mit Controller, ich sag's nur, die Controller Settings hier
unter Advanced ist alles richtig, aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen starten stellt sich
das immer wieder um auf Fullscreen 720p, warum, was leuchtet mir null ein, aber gut, mal ganz
im Ernst, ich glaube, das ist das, ich mach mal kurz die Musik aus, das ist das kleinste
Problem, was das Game hat, ich bin null eingespielt Leute, ich hab gerade Abend gegessen, ich
hab am letzten Arbeitstag gehabt, du hast dein 240Hz Monitor korrekt, ich hab gerade
erst angeschmissen hier alles, ich hab gearbeitet bis 16 Uhr, war da, hab ein bisschen Sport
gemacht und dann hab ich was gefressen und jetzt bin ich direkt am Rechner, wie gesagt,
genau dazu hab ich ein Video aufgenommen, nee, mein Monitor ist 240Hz, lehnst du mich
an? Ja, klar, mach ich, Monitor ist 240Hz, also Monitor ist, nein, ich spiel nicht 110er
FOF, das ist falsch, wenn die Anzeige da was von 110er FOF steht, guck mal hier, Sound,
Video, FOF, FOF ist 80, ich weiß nicht, ich komm irgendwie in Games nicht klar mit
riesem FOF, aber mit kleinem FOF auch nicht, ich bin irgendwie jemand, ich brauch so ein
Mittelding, weiß nicht, so, ja, ich lade dich ein, da kommen wir bestimmt in richtige
OP Lobbies, Leute, weiß jemand, ob es Matchmaking gibt, dass es Partys zu Partys matcht? Das
würde nämlich erklären, warum, wenn ich mit Leuten spiele, die gut sind bzw. in Party
bin, das deutlich schwitziger wird, als wenn ich alleine spiele. Findest du das neue Battle
Field schlecht? Schlecht ist so ein ultimatives Wort, aber wenn du das in einem Wort zusammenfassen
möchtest, dann find ich das neue Battle Field schlecht, aber da gehört noch viel mehr dazu,
als einfach nur zu sagen, dass es schlecht ist. Was ich vor allem schlecht finde, jetzt
ist unabhängig von was man persönlich von diesem Spiel hält, ich hab überhaupt keine
Probleme, wenn Leute den Spaß ihres Lebens, sag ich mal, jetzt mal haben in dem Spiel,
was ich persönlich ein bisschen doof finde, ist, dass wenn man diese Spiele, also wenn
man Spiele, wenn die so rauskommen im Zustand von Battle Field 2042 oder auch Warcraft 3
oder New World, wir hatten ja in letzter Zeit einige Releases, die nicht so gut funktioniert
haben, dann, wenn man das akzeptiert, ohne da mal wenigstens ein bisschen Gegenwind zu
verursachen, wisst ihr, das sorgt unterm Strich einfach nur, dass die Spiele noch schlechter
werden in Zukunft, weil man mit immer mehr durchkommt. Habt ihr übrigens schon die Metacritic
von Battle Field 2042 gesehen? Die ist umwerfend. Absolut umwerfend. Und auf Steam, und auf
Steam wird das Ganze noch besser, auf Steam ist es glaube ich das 5, 6, 7, 8, also innerhalb
der Top 10 schlecht bewertetsten Spiele des Jahres, des Jahres, das Jahr ist schon fast
um, das musst du erstmal schaffen. Mein schlechtester Hauptbattle Field Spiel aller Zeiten. Tja,
die Sache ist die, wie gesagt, das erzähle ich morgen im Video ein bisschen ausführlich,
die Sache ist die, der hat Recht, es ist das beste, es ist das schlechteste Hauptbattle
Field aller Zeiten und wisst ihr was das Bittere daran ist, dass das Spiel durchaus
Potenzial gehabt hätte. Ich sag hätte, weil das Spiel ist doppelt unfertig. Und das denke
ich ist das eigentliche Problem. Also was ich mit doppelt unfertig mein ist, das Spiel
ist nicht nur unfertig programmiert, das Spiel ist auch quasi gar nicht mal fertig
entworfen. Also das ist, dieses Spiel, das wirkt einfach als hätte man das genommen
und als hätte irgendein EA Manager gesagt, das kommt jetzt raus. Und alle haben gesagt
ja Moment, wir haben uns doch noch nicht mal ansatzweise für alles was überlegt, egal
das Spiel kommt jetzt raus. Das Spiel wirkt als hätte man das einfach mitten aus der
Entwicklung gerissen und mindestens ein Jahr zu früh rausgehauen. Hoffentlich Conquest
Smile. Also ich denke, der einfachste, das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, der einfachste
Fix, achso, ich hab dich eingeladen, das müsste eigentlich funktionieren. Ich denke,
der einfachste Fix, also den man schnell machen kann, weil alle anderen Fixes dauern
länger. Ich mein, baue die Maps mal um und eigentlich sollte, Captain Poggers, eigentlich
sollte das funktionieren hier mit dem Invite. Also der einfachste Fix, den man machen könnte,
wäre tatsächlich, man macht einen Spielmodus und beschränkt, ich weiß nicht wie die Maps
sich spielen auf PS4 oder Xbox One, keine Ahnung, da sind die Maps ja kleiner und besser,
also nicht besser, also kleiner und kompakter mit weniger Spielern, also potenziell besser,
das ist das, was ich sagen wollte. Und wenn die sowas als zusätzlichen Modus bringen,
das könnte erstmal so über das Gröbste hinweg helfen, weil die Maps haben durchaus ganz
gute Areale. Ja, ich mag zum Beispiel bei, ich kann mir immer die Map-Namen nicht mapen.
M, wie heißt die Container-Map? Manifest, Manifest, genau. Auf Manifest, auf dem Hügel
ist cool, übrigens es laggt und das ist normal, also es laggt bei mir immer im Hauptbildschirm,
in-game laggt es nicht, was auch sehr merkwürdig ist. Deswegen suchen wir jetzt einfach, wenn
wir ins Game gehen, dann ist es wieder flüssig. Es ist komisch, aber ja, es ist so. Mal Stats
an. What the fuck? Alter Battlefield, man. Und, wo bin ich denn jetzt gerade stehen geblieben?
Ja, Big, Low Brain, Alter. Ja, also das könnte man, das könnte man machen, dass man vielleicht
so ein kleineres Spiel hat, oben auf Manifest, genau, das war es, was ich sagen wollte, oben
auf Manifest ist ein cooles Gebiet, also da auf dem Berg oben drauf. Das Container-Feld
in Manifest finde ich ist eigentlich auch eine ganz coole Geschichte. Heute sind übrigens
die ganzen Neulinger am Start, die das Game erst jetzt neu spielen. Mal gucken, ob wir
heute noch ein bisschen, ob da ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen mehr reingeht und man nicht
von allen Seiten permanent weggegeiert wird. Und, also die meisten Maps haben ganz gute
Areale und wenn man dort vielleicht anbieten würde, man macht eine Domination oder sowas
zum Beispiel, das wäre ja was, muss ja kein TDM sein, dass man irgendwie Domination macht,
32 32 zum Beispiel. Mein persönlicher Favorit ist ja 24 24 immer gewesen, ehrlich gesagt,
ich halte 48 für die beste Spieleranzahl, aber das kommt natürlich auch ein bisschen
auf die Maps an. Ich glaube, das wäre ein Fix, den man relativ schnell und easy implementieren
könnte, weil eins ist auch klar, das Spiel hat schlicht, jetzt sollte es übrigens nicht
mehr ruckeln, wenn ich hier reingehe. Nee, jetzt ruckelt es doch nicht mehr, witzig.
Was sehen wir denn, wir spielen heute keine PP-Gar 29, da habe ich keinen Bock drauf.
Wollen wir mal ein Dings hier, M4, äh M5, sorry, sorry. Dieses Spiel ist ja in keinem
Zusammenhang mit Waffenherstellern, ja, legen sie auch Wert drauf. M5, äh Sensor, komm
wir nehmen mal, habe ich eben gerade beim Lost im Stream gesehen, ja, wenn der Lost das
dabei hat, dann Forsporn. Game, please. Aber es müsste flüssig sein eigentlich. Naja,
ist flüssig, ich sehe es gerade in der Vorschau, ist eigentlich ok. Alles, alles gut. Jetzt
habe ich vergessen, was ich ausrüsten wollte, ja, ich wollte, ich wollte Panzerplatten ausrüsten,
sehr gut, hat, hat nicht funktioniert. Oh man, schnelles Laufen ist auch broken wieder. Nice,
GG. Ok, wir müssen gleich das Loadout ändern. Was haben wir denn hier am Start? Äh Schnellfeuer,
Dings, Dings, ja das ist ok. Schauen wir mal, was da so abgeht, Bashen, Alter, Bashen.
Ich kann nicht immer, Alter, null W. Merd hat sie gesagt, hab das gehört, Merd. Ich wurde
gehackermant. Richtig hardcore hackermant. Merd, wo sind wir denn überhaupt? Merd. Boris,
Alter. Oh ne, ich bin wieder gehackt. Fuck, jetzt bin ich rausgesniped. Sombra 2.0, ja.
Das ist ein bisschen so, den habe ich selten gespielt in hackermant. Aber, wer mal ein
Video von heute gesehen hat, der weiß, dass man mit dem, mit dem hackermant, wobei, ne,
ne, das stimmt gar nicht, nicht mit diesem hackermant, oder? Warte mal, ich bin grad,
mit dem hier, den meine ich. Dass man mit diesem hackermant richtig geil XP farmen kann.
Soll ich euch mal die beste XP-Boosting-Taktik in diesem Spiel zeigen? Es ist, glaubt mir
Leute, es ist brain dead as fuck. Aber, ihr werdet leveln wie verrückt. Ich habe das nicht
oft gemacht, weil es einfach dumm ist, aber passt mal auf, es ist richtig dumm. Ihr legt
euch einfach hin, startet die Drohne und jetzt fliegt ihr in die Gegner und spottet. So
und ihr seht, ihr bekommt volle Kill-XP, volle Kill-XP und Spotting-XP für Gegner, die ihr
gespottet habt. Was im Endeffekt heißt, ihr fliegt einfach nur über die Map und spottet
euch den Fingerwund. Seht ihr, seht ihr die XP, seht ihr wie die krass die XP da reinkommt?
Und ihr tut noch was gutes fürs Team. Leider ist das absolute, ja wie soll ich sagen, so
Pepega. Richtig, richtige Pepega XP-Boost-Variante. Guckt euch mal an, guckt euch mal an, wie krass
ich XP reinkriege, einfach nur für Spotten. Am besten ist natürlich, ihr spottet Gegner,
die gekillt werden von eurem Team. Aber das ist mir jetzt zu dumm, wir gehen jetzt hier
mal rein. Ja ist gut, ist gut, dass du mich killst, weil die will ich eh nicht spielen.
Geil mache ich gleich, danke, ja easy. Easy Level 50. Ein bisschen höher fliegen, dann
siehst du auch wo du spotten musst, sind viele XPs, aber du kannst aber nicht zu
hoch fliegen, weil die Drohne hat Spotting-Radius. Also du kannst nicht von beliebiger Entfernung
spotten. Nehmen wir mal Panzerplatten, komm wir nehmen mal Panzerplatten. Easy Plates.
Einmal Panzerplatten, kommt euch die Animation irgendwo bekannt vor Leute? Kommt euch die
Animation irgendwie? Habt ihr die schon mal irgendwo gesehen? Wie ist das so? Kommt das
jemand bekannt vor diese Panzerplatten-Animation? Ne egal, das hat man doch nirgendswo gesehen.
Ja stimmt, stimmt. So und man kann übrigens auch anstatt mit dem Hacker-Man, kann man
mit den Motion-Sensors spotten, guckt. Da macht man Motion-Sensors rein und kriegt auch
Fett-XP. Wo sind die denn? Ach die haben uns Massive Big Brain geflankt. Verstehe, verstehe.
Die Sprint-Animation. Mir fällt da grad was auf. Ich muss mal kurz, wenn ich Maria Falk
spiele, ich muss mal schnell was umstellen. Nein, nein, das ist nicht neu. Wir wollen
das auf Fehl bearbeiten, wir wollen das auf 3 haben. Ich hab immer gern auf der Seitentaste
mein Self-Heal. Was ist denn hier los, Alter? Guckt euch das mal an. Das ist doch nicht
mehr normal. Da oben ist was. Auf, auf. Come on. Nein. Oh, oh, oh, oh, da steht er vor
mir. Wack. Direkt wack. Hast du das neue Cod schon gespielt? Nope. Du meinst Vanguard,
ne? Nee, hab ich nicht. Oh, ich hab ja Captain Pogger, der hat mich jetzt gerätzt. Nee,
hat er nicht, ist gar nicht. Okay, dann. Dachte, dachte nur, da ist einer auf mich zu, ist
einer auf mich zugelaufen. Und ja, ich würde gerne bei A2 spawnen. Ach, wir retaken das
gerade. Ah, yes. Retake. Wie schaut's in der SBMM-Front? Ich spiele heute meine ersten
Runden des Tages, keine Ahnung. Ich hab ja gesagt, heute sehen wir, ob's SBMM gibt,
heute sehen wir, ob's SBMM gibt. Äh, nämlich, ob wir gegen gute Gegner gematcht werden
oder nicht. Moment, Scoreboard. Lohnt, dazu bräuchte man ja ein Scoreboard. Ah, man sieht
ja nix. Ach, man sieht ja nix. Ah, ich vergaß, ich vergaß, man sieht ja nichts. Zack, ich
retz dich. Man sieht ja nichts. Ja, das ist natürlich dumm. Man weiß noch nicht mal,
ob man SBMMt wird. Ähm, ganz ehrlich, ich weiß, dass sie das gesagt haben mit ihrem
SBMM, aber, seriously, ich glaub denen kein Wort. Die haben ja bei Call of Duty auch bis
heute nicht mal das Acknowledged. Oh, meine Güte, was ist denn hier los? Kannste ja mal
voll vergessen. Äh, nicht mal bis heute Acknowledged, dass es SBMM gibt. Also, da gib ich nix drauf,
wenn ich ehrlich bin. Hab ich schon mal gesagt, dass ich diese Map überhaupt nicht mag?
Komm, wir spielen, was spielen wir denn mal? Pepega, nein, wir spielen nicht Pepega 29,
wir bleiben jetzt mal bei was anderem. Ich anlocke erstmal alles hierfür. Wir können,
aber ich sollte vielleicht was anderes spielen. Panzerplatte, nice. Ja, ein bisschen was mit
Mobility wäre hier nicht verkehrt. Das ist Breakthrough. Das ist Breakthrough mit 128
Spieler auf der größten Map, die es gibt. Leider ist es auch, finde ich, mit die schlechteste
Map im Spiel. Also, Größe ist nicht alles. Hallo, hallo, please, darf ich rauf? Was, danke.
In der Kopf. Oh, da war ein Gegner. Ich hab ihn gesehen. Aiaiai, aiaia, aiaia. Habt ihr
gesehen, wie es einfach durchgeflogen ist? Habt ihr es gesehen? Es ist einfach durchgeflogen.
Muss man, muss man sich dran gewöhnen. Es ist immer der, den du nicht siehst. Merkt
euch das. LMG, LMG legit. Chat sagt, Messern finde ich richtig unbelohnend. Ich mach so
gut wie Nahkampf-Kills. Ich mach so gut wie nie Nahkampf-Kills in dem Spiel. Also eigentlich
fast nie. So, stellst du mich hier mal lang? Ich spiele viel lieber Mobility-Helden. Bunker,
was ist hier los? Ich switche mal schnell, ich switche mal schnell auf was anderes. Wenn
Wheatle egal wird, kommt dann das Smoke-Stream. Nein. Lol, was eine Frage. Eine Frage. Midi-Pen.
Wow. Midi-Pen. Ja, das ist dumm. Muss ich schon wieder umstellen. Das ist halt kacke,
dass das unterschiedlich ist. Muss ich mir mal was überlegen. Ob ich irgendwie einen
Hotkey mache zum Ummappen meiner Maus oder so. Monka, habt ihr gesehen was da hinten
los ist man? Das ist ja definitiv nicht normal, was da los ist. Ok, wir probieren mal was
los. Achtung, Achtung. Yolo. Was willst du machen? Und ich war direkt auf dem Kopf von dem Dude.
Wenn er nur zwei Schuss rausgekommen wäre er tot, aber nope. Ja, warum man jetzt hier...
Mist, zu spät. Wir gehen einfach in den Heli und machen richtig Pog aus Flank. Mal hier,
mal hier. Also man sieht der Map-Designer hat das glaube ich so in der Mittagspause
gemacht, weil es gibt ja nichts, es gibt ja nichts. Ice-TDs. Alter. Ich habe den Schnellfeuerlauf
drauf, das ist ziemlich sackig auf Range. Hallo, please spring, spring, spring. Auf und runter
zu fallen wäre schon äußerst nice. Nice, next please. Da ist ein Hover. Oh wisst ihr was, wir spawnen jetzt auch ein Hover. Oh nee, kein Hovercraft da.
Wir können Ranger spawnen, das ist vielleicht gar nicht so blöd. Ranger, oh hier ist gerade
über mich drüber geflogen. Nice, next please. Der hat zu spät geladen, der hat zu spät geladen.
Alter, ich dachte es ist ein Gegner, man. Übrigens, was ich auch am Anfang nicht gecheckt habe,
man kann einfach die Muni wechseln und sobald man die Muni wechselt, hat man volle, volle Muni
wieder. Aber es ist eine andere Munition, das muss man wissen. Also die Munition unterscheiden
sich tatsächlich je nach Typ. Es gibt Munition, die schießt schneller, wie auch immer sie
das in-Game erklären wollen, dass Munition schneller schießt, man weiß es nicht so genau,
aber ok. Munition, die mehr Range hat, Munition, die weniger auf der Minimap sichtbar ist oder
irgendwie sowas, habe ich nicht gecheckt. Essen. Ja, ok, bis gleich, Herr Poggers. Wo
sind wir hier eigentlich? Übrigens, wo sind wir auf der Minimap? Erkennt ihr es Leute,
wir sind dieser Strich. Das erkennt man nicht so wirklich gut. Wo ist hier was? Wo ist hier
was? Entehakenstells. Entehakenstells. Oh, da sind sie, da sind sie. Oh, ich muss hier
hoch. Alter, die müssen gebashed werden. Nein. Natürlich, klar, da sitzt er hinten,
logisch. Geht doch eigentlich ganz gut rein. Oh, huge Red Source. Nice, nice, nice. Ok,
jetzt probiere ich es nochmal. Ah, gut, sehr gut. Ah, ja, ja, ja. Die SVK ist pure Hass.
Ich kann mir, ich habe noch ehrlich gesagt, ich habe nicht einmal außer Pickup Sniper
gespielt. Ist das die One-Hit-Sniper? Sag mal, ist mein Entehaken kaputt? Ja, ja, ist irgendwie
kaputt. Ist das die One-Hit-Sniper? Ja, es gibt eine One-Hit-Sniper. Oh, ich glaube,
jetzt sind wir, jetzt sind wir down. Und wir haben die Objectives verloren. Na gut. Oh,
hier, ich muss da rein, muss da rein und runterspringen. Sundance an Start, kleinere Hitbox,
Motion Sensor, sollte ich vielleicht auch ein bisschen mehr verwenden. Wobei ich mit
Sundance Axe und Smoke Granaten ganz gut finde. Lass mich rein, Gachi Bass. Muss rein und
abspringen. Please. Nein, ich darf nicht. Das ist aber blöd. Hätte ich doch den anderen
vielleicht nehmen sollen. So, passt mal auf, ich zeige euch mal die längste Zip-Line des
Universums. Also wenn ihr mal AFK müsst, so auf Klo oder was zu trinken holen müsst
oder sowas. Dann geht ihr hier, macht hier Breakaway an und geht hier an dieses Zip-Line
und dann hopp. Excellent, excellent. Erstmal kurz hier das Weinglas rausholen. So, gleich
sind wir oben. Sehr gut. Sind deine EA-Sponsored-Videos jetzt rum? Echt schade, dass du so ein kaputtes
Spiel noch Promo machen musstest. Naja, was heißt musstest, das ist ja nicht so, als
kriege ich da nicht was für. Ne, eins müsst ihr noch ertragen, eins zu Hazard Zone. Ich
habe mich zu drei Sponsored-Videos hinreißen lassen. In 20 Sekunden Zip-Line, ja. Ich finde
auch daran sieht man, dass die Maps ein bisschen groß sind. What, ist da hinten was? Meine
Boomer-Augen machen das nicht mit. Außerdem habe ich keine Range-Waffe, vielleicht sollte
ich mal auf eine ordentliche Range-Waffe switchen. Ich habe hier höchstens, ich habe hier eigentlich
Close-Quarter-Mid-Range-Waffe. Höchstens Mid-Range, maximal Mid-Range. Ui. Okay, das hat nicht
so gut geklappt, wie mir das vorgestellt habe. Okay. Ich check noch nicht mal, wo sind denn
wir eigentlich jetzt? Sind wir im Spawn von denen? Ja, wir sind, wir sind ver... Und hier
ballert der Heli krass rein. Hier oben geht was ab. Oh, oh, oh, hier will ich, hier will
ich nicht rein, aber was soll ich sonst machen? Ich bin, ich bin, okay. Ich, ich werfe mal
kurz eine Anti-Air... Ja, ja, ist okay, weg. Eine Anti-Air-Hint, dass es die Flares von
dem Typ droppt. Okay, das hat nichts gebracht. War echt verwirrt auf YouTube nach dem Video
von gestern aus dem Streamchat. Ja, was soll ich sagen? Manchmal muss ich auch ein bisschen
Geld verdienen. Mein Gott, was haben die sich denn hierbei gedacht? Ja, das ist kein Problem.
Ach, geht gar nicht. Aber wir haben es bald geschafft. Also, ich hoffe, wir schaffen
die Base zu halten, dann ist vorbei. Ansonsten geht das noch... Letzte Base ist da hinten
auf der Ölplattform, das geht da noch ein bisschen. Oh, Granatuh. Ups. Sag mal, kann
das sein, dass wir voll, voll upside sind? Dass wir vielleicht mal lieber zu B runter
sollten, anstatt hier am Spawn rum zu campen? Ist vielleicht richtig dumm, am Spawn rum
zu campen? Ich glaube schon, ich glaube, das ist massiv Pepega am Spawn rum zu campen.
Das ist schon cool. Also, es hat schon so seine Momente, das ist schon cool. Guckt euch das
mal an, es ist schon nice, also diese Sache mit dem Rumfliegen hier. Ich habe übrigens
die Gegner gesehen. Oh, Pepega hat weg, Pepega. Nooo. Burst Fire, Max, Burst Fire. Hätte ich
gewusst, Burst Fire. Easy Win. Easy Win. Easy Win. Easiest Win of my life eigentlich.
Gehen wir mal B1 rein. Oder einfach PP29 spielen. Ja, also das Setup für die ist halt eigentlich
auch richtig, richtig dumm. Ich sollte das mal kurz umstellen. Nämlich, jetzt können
wir dieses Feature ja auch mal verwenden. Wir machen jetzt einfach langer Lauf rein.
Die da und der Rest ist ok. Wir könnten mal sogar irgendeinen Scope drauf machen. Vielleicht
klappt das jetzt besser. Also hier müssten auf jeden Fall gleich welche stelzen. Guck,
es ist gleich viel langsamer. Und jetzt sehe ich nichts. Und es kommt, ah nice, GG. Jetzt
können wir mal einen Motion Sensor, ach das ist gar keiner, das ist Smoke. Sehr clever,
Max, sehr clever. Massive, bester Smoke EU hier, guckt euch den an. So ein krasser Smoke,
man. Ist da einer an B1? Soll der Day One Patch kommen? Der Day One Patch kam gestern.
Und der Day One Patch hat dafür gesorgt, dass eigentlich so gut wie nichts gefixt wurde.
Der Day One Patch hat also wirklich, also Rubber Bending ein bisschen reduziert, aber ansonsten,
oh was ist denn da? Was ist denn da los? Was ist denn hier los? Ich will eigentlich da
oben rauf, Pog. Und jetzt hier, nein, nein, nein, nein. Alles klar, sehr schön. Man,
weiß nicht wo drauf ich gucken soll. 308, Pog, das war richtig dumm. Wisst ihr was ich
gemerkt habe? Umso älter ich werde, es ist jetzt kein hier übliche Geschichte, Recycle
Story Geschichten aus dem Krieg, umso älter ich werde, ich brauche umso länger, bis ich
irgendwie halbwegs warm bin. Also was heißt warm? Also ihr wisst was ich meine. Ich brauche
mittlerweile fast 45 Minuten, bis ich ansatzweise mir Mühe gebe und anfange mich in Game zu
fühlen. Läuft das Spiel besser? Ich habe gerade 110 FPS, das ist okay. Richtig, Rentner.
Was ist Rubber Bending? Das wirst du oft genug sehen heute Abend noch. Man kann die eigentlich
rausschießen, wenn man weiß wo man hinschießen muss. Okay. PP29, PP29. Aim Level Boomer, ja
mein Gott ey, aber gerade ist es wirklich ganz abartig. Wir machen jetzt, wir machen
erstmal was anderes. Ich habe keinen Bock immer PP29 zu spielen, aber was willst du
machen? Was willst du machen? PP29, Easy Mode. Easy Mode Activated. Langer Lauf drauf, das
war das da, wunderbar. Power Gas, auf gehts. Mir müsste es mal so machen, dass ich da hin
fliegen kann. PP29, ja. Darf ich hier starten vielleicht? Nein, nein, nein, lass mich nur.
Hallo, ich würde gerne abheben, Game. Darf ich abheben, please? Ich glaube, das muss
steiler sein. Nein. Abheben nicht erlaubt. Aber abheben von diesem kleinen Felsvorsprung
wird wahrscheinlich funktionieren. Was auch. Hakt würde ich das, ne? Guck mal was die
für ein Speed hat von diesem Felsvorsprung. Aber B2, was sollen wir auf B2? Oh, warum nicht?
B2. Gucken wir mal, ob da irgendwas ist. Oh, ich höre einen Hovercraft. Wollen wir auch
einen Hovercraft holen? Hallo? Nice Pog. Nice Pog. Da ist es. Oh, nein, nein, nicht mich
killen jetzt, bevor ich meinen Hovercraft habe. So. Seriously. Seriously. Der weiß
gelobert. Jetzt hat er meins geklaut. Mein Gott, war das schlecht. Guck da einfach raus.
Guck da einfach raus. Was machen wir denn jetzt? Ich bin vollkommen lost, Alter. Oh,
weiß was? Ja. Oh. By the way, man kann die Leute rausschießen aus dem. Manchmal, manchmal
klappt das. Man kann die Leute rausschießen mit dem, mit dem, mit dem grappling hook.
Oh. Okay. Der farmt sich, der farmt sich dumm und dämlich, der Typ hier. Ich sag's euch.
Der Hovercraft, man. Nice. Sag mal. Maxi, ich hau dich doch wegen des Skill-Apples.
Ja, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Gerade besonders. Gerade ist richtiges High-Skill angesagt.
Wir haben gewonnen, easy. Gott sei Dank, gescheite Map. Also hoffentlich jetzt gescheite, weil
irgendwann wieder Breakaway kommt da nicht. Warst du schon tot? Nee. Hat sich gleich ausgeruht,
aber tot kann man... Nee, nee, nee, nee. Das geht gar nicht. Ich hab das Game schon gehackermant.
Ich kann immer sterben. Das sieht alles nur so aus. Cacombo. Victory. Genau. Was ich auch
bei der Story nicht verstehe ist, wenn das... Na gut, so beschissen war man dann doch nicht.
Wahrscheinlich weil der Cap'n Poggers geohnt hat. Das ist ja so Welt am Abgrund und sowas.
Seht ihr, das war rein wegen dem Spotten am Anfang. Welt am Abgrund, Hungersnöte und
sonst was. Aber es ist immer noch US vs. Russland in den Matches. Warum auch immer. Und von
dem ganzen, von dieser eigentlich düsteren vorhandenen Background-Story ist eigentlich
nichts da. Also, die machen coole Sprüche, die Specialists und davor, vor dem Game und
nach dem Game und in dem Game und... Also, ich merk davor nichts. Continue. Okay, wenn
der Cap'n Poggers ist essen, dann... Oder bist du wieder da? Wenn nicht, lief ich mal
kurz. Nein, dann Cancel. Cancel. Ich hab das nicht wieder da. Wie lief man eigentlich
die Party? Rechtsklick. Lief Party. Okay. Dann spielen wir noch ne Runde Projekt. Hoffentlich
jetzt ein gescheites Map. Also, ich sag mal so. Aus meiner Sicht. Das Spiel hat eine wirklich
gute Map. BF. Das ist übrigens normal, dass es im Hauptbildschirm ruckelt. Der Rest ist
in Ordnung. Versteh auch nicht, warum es nur im Hauptmenü ruckelt. Keine Ahnung. Das
weil es wahrscheinlich nicht mal da ist. So, Maps. Genau. Also, ich muss sagen, es gibt
eine wirklich gute Map, wie ich finde. Manifest. Manifest ist nice. Es gibt bei den anderen
Maps leider nicht so viel Gutes. Hourglass finde ich nicht gut wegen den Hochhäusern.
Discarded ist mir viel zu offen, aber ich glaube Heliflieger haben richtig Bock auf Discarded.
Kaleidoskop ist ganz brauchbar in Breakthrough leider nicht wegen dem Hochhaus. Orbital ist,
die haben keinen Mist erzählt. Die haben in der Beta gesagt, Orbital ist ihre beste Map
und ich muss sagen, es ist tatsächlich eine der besten Maps. Leider in Breakthrough auch
wegen dem Hochhaus nicht so richtig spielbar. Aber Breakaway, dazu kann ich nur sagen. Als
anderes fällt mir nicht ein. Also Breakaway mag ich überhaupt gar nicht. Und Renewal,
die ist eigentlich ganz okay. Ich finde Renewal ist die beste Breakthrough Map. Vielleicht
spielen wir die jetzt auch. Nein. Wir spielen Hourglass. OMG. Hourglass. Please. Pepega
Claes. Und wir sind auch noch Defender. Das wird was. Oh, ich Pepega Claes. Der Anfang
geht ab der zweiten Base wird das ganz, ganz mir. Und die Attacker spawnen übrigens da
oben drauf. Das heißt eigentlich muss man hier gar nicht weiter ranpushen, sondern kann
sich hier schon irgendwie ein bisschen vercampen. Und wenn man da oben drauf geht, wird man in
der Regel weggesniped aus dem Spawn. Guck, da liegen sie schon. Da liegen sie schon. Also
hier ist erst mal Instant Death angesagt. Egal auf welcher Seite. Wir smokeen da mal
kurz eine Runde rein, dass das Hovercraft uns nicht so abpackt. Okay oder auch so. Und
wir nehmen mal Motion Sensors mit, weil Motion Sensors wirklich äußerst praktisch sind.
Das macht XP und das deckt Gegner auf. Das ist eigentlich das Beste, was wir jetzt machen
können. So, hauen wir das mal rein. Ja, lass mich doch mal wenigstens überhaupt hier in
das Game rein. Hab ich schon mal gesagt, wie Pepega das ist auf der Map? Ab der zweiten
Base ist es für die Defender ein Ticken besser. Guckt mal, das ist eines der Sachen, das sage
ich auch immer im Video morgen, oder habe ich heute schon aufgenommen, wo man eigentlich
offensichtlich sieht, dass 128 Spieler nicht richtig funktionieren. Es quetschen sich jetzt
hier 64 vs. 64 in den Spot, wo früher 16 vs. 16 und 32 vs. 32 war. Auf einer Base.
Was willst du machen? Was willst du machen? Es gibt ja eigentlich nichts, es gibt ja nicht
wirklich was, was du machen kannst. Außer versuchen sich hier zu verpissen irgendwie
und abzuhauen und was auch immer und sich bashen zu lassen und keine Ahnung. Motion
Sensor vorhauen, dass man was sieht. Da gibt es wenigstens XP, wenn man den Motion Sensor
am Start hat. Ist einfach die Mauer weg. Chat sagt, irgendwie gibt es gar keine Balanced
Sensor. Also ich finde Manifest ist ok. Ansonsten ist ja schon ziemlich pepega. Ab hier wird
es tatsächlich jetzt ein bisschen besser. Komm wir spielen mal was an, ich habe keinen
Bock immer diese pepega Waffe zu spielen. Was haben wir hier schönes zu bieten? Kein
Laufding, ich habe hier kaum was anlockt, wie es aussieht. Hovercraft, Hovercraft, was
sonst? Hovercraft. Noch mehr Hovercraft, sehr gut. Pepega Field 2042. Können auch nicht
vor. Ja gut, dann warten wir mal. Wisst ihr in anderen Games hätten wir jetzt so einen
Spray Paint oder sowas, was man an die Maps machen kann? Motion Sensor. Kann man die
Dinge eigentlich zerstören? Nee. Ich dachte ich probiere es mal. Oh hier kommt bestimmt
klar was durch. Kein Gewehr.
Erstmal schön abcampen das Fenster. Ich werde jetzt einfach weiter Motion Sensor werfen und
da rein Sprayen. Was anderes mache ich nicht, easy. Ok das war richtig rein pepega, sehr
viel. Ok hier ist nichts. Motion Sensor, Motion Sensor. Ok das ist für mich, das ist für
mein Boomer-Aim perfekt. Ich muss einfach nur gerade ausschießen. Einfach nur geradeaus.
So was wir jetzt mal ausprobieren können ist wir können hier mal aufs Dach, uns aufs
Dach stellzen. Ok wenn der grappling hook geht dann stellzen wir uns aufs Dach. Und da ein
klitschen sehen und dann gucken wir mal ob wir irgendwie durchkommen, wahrscheinlich
sterben wir. Ich will hier von der Seite rein fahren. Pack hier ist nichts. Ok mal hinlegen.
Ah das ist ein Hovercraft da vorne, da machst du eh nichts gegen. MonkaS, das ist der Heli
der mich basht. Muss weg, muss weg, noch ein paar Motion Sensors rein, sehr gut. So mal
gucken ob jetzt da was rankommt. Haben die schon was gecaptchert? Jo die sind da hinten
am Start. Ok dann sollte ich mich jetzt hier einfach mal verpissen wenn es geht. Wenn ich
irgendwie rauskomme wäre hier wirklich ganz gut. Weil ich glaube die überrennen uns jetzt
hier vorne. Wo sind wir denn hier am Start? Ah ok. B3, dann order der Wüsten, der Dünenstelz
ist jetzt angesagt, der Dünenstelz. Ja das macht ihr schon da hinten, das macht ihr
schon. Wir beteiligen uns etwas am Dünenstelz. Gucken wir mal, da fährt immer einer von
der Seite rein. Von wo? Von hinten. Es ist auf einen Gegner den du siehst, mindestens
5 den du nicht siehst. Oh Sturm, Sturm hatte ich hier noch nie auf der Map. Alter wo hat
denn das, mein Gott wo schießt, wo schießt das Ding hin? Oh das Hovercrafted hier, es
ist wild, wild Hovercrafted. Richtig wild. Massive wilder Hovercraft. Ein wildes Hovercraft
erscheint. Ok, ich weiß nicht genau wohin, ich hoffe mich sieht keiner. Nein nein ihr
seht mich nicht. Alles klar ihr seht mich nicht, ich weiß dass ihr mich nicht seht.
Und war der Patch Gameplay technisch förderlich? Nö es hat sich nichts geändert. Es hat sich
nichts geändert. Ist das alles ein bisschen? Hat das Ding einen langen Lauf oder sowas?
Irgendwas was ein bisschen mehr Range hat? Komm wir müssen doch mit der Pepega 29 ran.
Die Steam Bewertung ja, die Steam Bewertung ist brutal. Aber das Spiel hat sich das schon
verdient irgendwo. Das Spiel hat sich schon verdient. LMG, ne LMG, LMG legit, LMG mag
ich nicht. So jetzt müssen wir ein bisschen was drauf legen hier. Ich will das nicht
verlieren. Weil dann dauert das ja noch länger. Was ist denn das Problem? So Motion Sensors
reinkloppen. Poggers. Ich sollte einfach Selfie, Selfie. METF was zum Geier? Wie soll das denn
laufen hier jetzt? Können wir vielleicht irgendwie die Massive Huge Flank Action machen
oder so? So vielleicht ein bisschen Zickzack, ein bisschen Zick, nein ok. Wir haben schon
sehr viele Spieler verloren haben. Ja die meisten kommen ja heute dabei. Ne das wird
nix mehr. Bleibt aber nix anderes übrig hier. Oh der hat ne gute Pose, da kann man bestimmt
einfach 3, 3, 4 Gegner weghauen. Was zum Teufel war die denn? Und die andere Richtung auch
noch. Ok, ich weiß nicht so genau. Aber hier auf der Map war doch brutal viel gerade. Man
kann übrigens auch nicht zoomen auf der Map. Ich hab keine Ahnung wo wir sind. Wo sind
wir überhaupt? Wir sind hier. Weg! Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne. Kann ich die Oma retzen? Oma ich
retz dich. Oh ne der Rätsel ist verbugt, shit. Psst, hören, hören. Das ist die Oma die
gerade respawned ist. Hier ist nix mehr. Sicher sein kann man sich in dem Game eh nicht. Die
Performance, Alter. Das hört sich an wie irgendwie so ein Bausparvertrag von irgendeiner
Bank. Wüsten Performance 200 oder sowas. Äh die ist immer noch nicht wirklich gut.
Oh nein. Ich hab mich gut von hinten angestellt. Das Problem ist da ist nix außer ein Panzer.
Und auf der anderen Seite ist auch ein Panzer. Und Schneiber und alles. Ah hier da. Und
gegenüber liegend ist auch was. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Lass mich in Ruhe. Nein. Jetzt
war es der Panzer. Ok. Hat sich leicht verbessern. Ne finde ich nicht. Ich meine ich mach mal
hier guck mal. Perf, Overlay, Draw, FPS 1. Dann sieht man auch ein bisschen wo es bottleneckt.
Moin, Chain Law. Warum spielt niemand Red Dot? Doch, doch. Gibt genug die Red Dot spielen.
Oh der ist gut paranziert. Nice. Aha. Was? Ist das gerade mitten durch seinen Kopf durchgeflogen?
Ist das mitten? Was? Vielleicht krieg ich nen Rätsel. Das wär Massive Poggers. Er lebt
ja noch. Nein, Mist. Ich bin was? Sagt ihr mal ich bin legit CPU von 30 auf 50 hoch und
jetzt ist es spielbar. Was wie? Welche CPU von 30 auf 50? Du meinst denke ich nicht Temperatur
weil das wär ein bisschen niedrig? Oder meinst du Auslastung? Ach mehr FPS. Achso. Also
das einzige was ein bisschen besser geworden ist, ist das ultra krasse Rubber Bending was
du hattest und das Laggen. Also so richtig harte Serverlags hatte ich jetzt noch nicht
seit diesem Day One Patch. Aber ansonsten, na weiß nicht. Ein Motion Sensor rüber kloppen.
Da kommt was hier. Ja, Gegner. Nice. Nächster Motion Sensor einfach hier Big Brain Motion
Sensor. Wie kommen wir jetzt hier von drüben? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Nö, nö, so nicht.
Oh jetzt ein Smoke Nade. Ihr Medikoma Stelz. Ok, wie kommen wir jetzt hier mal raus? Von
hinten vielleicht? Weil das Contest, ach ich darf mal nicht durch. Warum ist die zu die
Tür? Da ist nichts dahinter. Was, was ist das? Was haben sich die Araber oder wer auch immer
das gebaut hat hier gedacht? Was ist das? Das ist eine gute Idee, wir machen die Tür
einfach zu, weil, weil da ist die Düne dahinter. Ach Mensch, warum ist da jetzt ein Pantsman?
Was, wie kommt man auf so eine klorische? Ja, nee, nee, nee, da hinten kleben wir einfach
mal Klebeband vom Ikea drüber. Gibt es eigentlich Rush im Hauptspiel? Nope. Oh, schnell, schnell,
schnell spawnen bevor es weg ist. Nein, es gibt keinen Rush im Hauptspiel. Es gibt Breakthrough
und es gibt Conquest. Und rate mal, was es noch gibt. Breakthrough, Conquest und Postchamp,
was gibt es noch? Richtig sehr raten. Nichts. Ah, der lebt gar nicht mehr. Kommt noch ein
Update? Ja, das weiß keiner. Also wann und wie? Es gibt Gerüchte und ja, es kommen noch
Updates. Ich glaube, am 30. kommt noch eins. Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, wo hier überhaupt
irgendwas abgeht. Da oben ist ein Gegner. Oh, habe ich jetzt? Habe ich jetzt Burst drin?
Jetzt, jetzt, wo ich den Burst drin habe, ne? Ppega 29. 27 ist es. Oh, das war so der typische
Fall. Nice und dann Zedge. Direkt innerhalb von einer Sekunde zusammen. Pog, Zedge. Respawn
Timer Active. Respawn Timer Active. Oh, nee. Vielleicht kriegen sie es wieder. Vielleicht
kriegen sie es wieder. Da, da, da will ich nicht hin. Jawoll, jawoll, nehmt ein. Nein,
nehmt ein. Ah, sehr gut, sehr gut. Oh, nee. Hofferstelz, Hofferstelz. Nehmt ein. Die
trauen sich nicht auf den Punkt, Leute. Einnehmen, einnehmen, einnehmen. Prege, Prege. Prege.
Prege erfolgreich. Oh, ich schmeiße mal ein paar Motion Sensors rüber. Also ich weiß
überhaupt nicht, wo ich hin soll. Das ist so offen und so flach. Ok, aber hier ist ein
Motion Sensor. Ok. Alles klar, alles, alles klar. Du, genau da, wo man herkommt und Motion
Sensor, genau da steht da hinter einem. Was sonst? Ah, wir haben es wieder verloren, Mist.
Vielleicht kommen wir hier noch schnell rein. Nein, nicht sterben, Leute. Come on. Jawoll.
Oh, oh, oh, wo sind wir denn hier? Oh, Hover, Hovercraft, Hovercraft. Noch mehr Hovercraft,
Panzer. Ich muss hier weg. Ok, Jesus, ich rette dich. Da bist du auf meiner Seite, da
gewinnen wir easy. Jesus, Jesus ist am Start. Aaron, Jesus. Jetzt haben wir eigentlich schon
so gut wie gewonnen. Jesus, Jesus ist dabei. Weiter geht's. Ich habe legit keine Ahnung,
wo ich hin soll. Es ist mir absolut unbegreiflich, was hier. Oh no. Weg, weg, weg. Next. Angeblich
ist hier was. Sind die hier dahinter? Ok, nice. Mein Heal geht nicht. Warum geht mein
Heal nicht? Mein Selfheal geht nicht. Ah, jetzt geht er. Ok, alles klar. Ich habe diesen
Medipen sehe ich gerade. Ich habe einen Medipen und Selfheal. Das ist ziemlich, ziemlich massiv
pepega. Das habe ich vergessen zu switchen. Also mehr pepega geht eigentlich gar nicht.
Ich habe dich gesehen, ich habe dich gesehen. Ok, Rätzke. Um die Ecke, um die Ecke Rätzke.
Nein. Boris. Weg. Boris. Doppelheal, ja Doppelheal ist krasseste Pepega Style aller Zeiten.
Meins Doppelheal, Doppelstonks. Wenn wir mit dem Trend gehen, müsste ich den zweiten
Heal als NFT verkaufen oder sowas. Ammo Box? Ammo Box ist ziemlich nice, dann kann man seine
Motion Sensoren weiter auffüllen. Oh, wir haben das eingenommen. Huge Pog. Da sieht
man schon mal, was ich finde, was nicht so schön ist im Vergleich zu Rush. In Rush ist
das M, komm weg. Ne Platte, ich mag Platten nicht. Tank. Da hinne, sonst wo. Aber eigentlich
ist Platte wirklich das beste, aber ich verachte diese Platten in dem Game eher. Ich finde,
das ist eine dumme Idee gewesen. Gerade wenn man auf Gegner mit Platten trifft, das ist
noch Doppel Pepega. Können wir irgendwo hin, wo nicht 50 Milliarden Gegner sind? Hier vielleicht.
Ja, es gibt Armour Plates, korrekt. Richtig erkannt. Problem ist, wenn wir hier lang gehen,
wenn wir instant, instant in die Seite Gachi Bust. Wo willst du hin? Oder wie der echte
Gangster jetzt sagen würde, was willst du tun? Motion Sensor, mal hoch. Oh, oh, oh,
jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen hier. Noch ein Motion Sensor, direkt nach oben. Ich weiß
nämlich, oh nice, nice shield, nice shield. Pogas Schild, Pogas Schild. Vielleicht kann
ich hier irgendwas droppen. Oh, wir machen jetzt das. Wir machen jetzt ein Hovercraft
und fahren in die, fahren alle Gegner um. Please, please drop. Scheiße, sagt sie. Okay,
es hätte funktionieren können. Es hätte funktionieren können. Vom Ansatz her, vom
Ansatz her nicht schlecht. Guck mal, wir haben das andere auch fast eingenommen. Das ist ja
richtig nice. Mal in diesen super realistisch fliegenden Heli einsteigen. Respawn Timer Active.
Denn die Sache bestimmt nur in der englischen Version scheiße. In der deutschen Version
ist es sicherlich abgeschwächt, weil es geht ja nicht, dass da einer Scheiße sagt.
Platte rein. Genau das. Ich sollte mal anfangen mit dem Ding ordentlich zu schießen, weil
normalerweise muss man damit so schießen. Dann trifft man nämlich auch was. Okay, volle
Pulle. Gib alles. Gib alles. Gib Gas. Bravo Two. Oh, da kommt was. Da kommt was. Müssen
gebashed werden. Nice. Oh, da unten links ist noch was. Achtung. Oh nein, nein, nein,
lass mich irgendwo. Platte rein. Platte rein. Midi-Pack. Heal. Heal. Ich bin dumm, warum
spritze ich mir das in den Arm, damit kann man es auf den Boden schießen. Du musst
hier in dem Spiel, kannst du vorausgehen, wenn du einen Gegner siehst, haben dich 10
andere gesehen und dementsprechend musst du dich nach einem Kill direkt verpissen. Sonst
ist Deadge oder so oder Snipege oder irgendwie auf jeden Fall ist dann vorbei. Da sind aber
viele aus meinem Team. Vielleicht habe ich Glück. Nee, da rätst mich niemand. Das wäre
ja fast Selbstmord da. Revive Action zu machen. Oh nice, guck mal da. Man kann das nämlich
auf den Boden schießen und drüber laufen und schon. Oh, Overtime, wir haben es. Win.
Hyper S. Max, kannst du mal bitte SKV testen? Wenn ich Sniper spielen muss, dann wisst ihr
was passiert. Oh, der hat diese Grinsprüche. Ich war 1-2 Stunden am Start. Ja, er hat sich
entweitet. Ich muss ja mal schreiben, dass ich am Streamson bin. Sonst am Streamson,
ich entweite dich. Er kann richtig gut Heli fliegen. Lohnt sich das Spiel zu kaufen? Meine
ehrliche Meinung ist nein, zumindest jetzt noch nicht und es gibt aber noch kein Scoreboard.
Ich hätte echt gerne gesehen, was bei dem Game rauskommt, wenn sie noch in Jahrzeiten
gehabt hätten. Weil es ist ja ein Unterschied. Das glaube ich auch vielen nicht klar. Es
ist ja ein Unterschied, ob das Spiel jetzt rauskommt und dann über irgendwie ein Jahr
live quasi gepatcht wird oder ob die nun ein Jahr wirklich Hardcore fokussiert dran entwickeln
und machen können, was sie wollen. So ein Party? Ah, jetzt. Okay, nice. Happen Poggers,
bist du eigentlich wieder da? Spielen wir mal aus. Vielleicht ist er wieder da. Ah,
da ist er wieder. Play. Die Menüerfahrung ist nervig. Übrigens, dass es im Hauptmenü
ruckel ist normal, im Spiel ruckelt es nicht. Ich würde es nicht Menüerfahrung nennen,
weil Menüerfahrung klingt in irgendwie Art und Weise so, als wäre das jetzt super erhellend,
wenn man dieses Menü benutzen muss. Es ist eher Menüzumutung. Klar, streng genommen
heißt Erfahrung einfach nur, man hat es erfahren. Gibt es einen Day One Patch? Ja. Und der
Day One Patch hat eigentlich nichts gefixt. So, wo sind wir denn hier gelandet? Ah, Broken
Server. Das kommt auch manchmal vor. Ich lief mal wieder in der Hoffnung. Oh nein, jetzt
habe ich die Party gelieft. Warum ist der Knopf auch da an der gleichen Stelle? Oh,
ich entweite euch nochmal. So, mal gucken, ob es jetzt wieder funktioniert. Sagt die
Performance immer noch? Ja, ziemlich. Ich habe Glück, es funktioniert halbwegs. Ich
habe auch keine Ahnung, warum ich mit meinem jetzt nicht ganz neuen PC, sagen wir mal so,
FPS habe beim Stream. Übrigens, dass es laggt, ist normal im Menü. Im Spiel laggt es da
nicht. Ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt, dass es im Menü laggt. Aber hier kein Schimmer.
Vielleicht liegt es daran, dass im Menü die CPU-Auslastung höher ist als im Spiel. Guckt
mal. Wobei, jetzt geht es eigentlich. Ah doch. Alter, guckt euch mal an. Der Rechner hat
einfach 80, 90, 100% CPU-Auslastung vom im Menü sein. Lull. Das musste er erst mal schaffen.
Okay, auf geht's. Richtig heftigster Monk hast dir. Ne, du, danke schön für den Sub.
Ich bin wieder zu blöd, zu multitasking. Ich checke wieder nicht, wann was ist. Ne,
du hat gesubbt. Danke schön. Wen haben wir hier noch sonst noch am Start? Jan, du war
gestern schon da. Habe ich gar nicht gesehen. Weiß. Wollte ich jetzt sagen noch. Ach ja,
habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich ab jetzt... Oh bitte. Habe ich euch erzählt, dass ich
ab jetzt Urlaub habe. Also quasi so richtig echt so für das restliche Jahr bis Januar.
Habe ich jetzt eigentlich hier die Vektor am Start? Noch nicht. Aber gibt's bald. Okay
komm, wir probieren uns mal noch ein bisschen an was anderes. Ich kann, ich kann, ich halte
es nicht aus, wenn ich jedes Mal, jedes Mal PP-Gar 29 spiele. Wir sind, sind wir Defens?
Wir sind Defen. Bis Januar, ja. Dem Chef vor das Büro gekackt. Nein, BTF. Ich würde
meinem Chef auch nie also irgendwas Böses wünschen. Also es ist aktuell. Und nein,
ich schleime jetzt nicht, weil ich weiß, dass er mein Stream kennt und manchmal guckt.
Oh, wir haben hier den Waffen-Bug. Sehr gut. GG. Ja, ich würde gerne meine Waffe customisern
im Game. Das ist der beste Chef, den ich je hatte in diesem Laden. Also das ist der erste,
der macht, was er soll und auf einen hört, auch wenn man sagt, dass das technisch blöd
ist. Kann ich nichts, kann ich echt nichts sagen. Oh, da kommt ein Hovercraft. Wer hätte
das gedacht? Nee, es ist ein Panzer und ein Auto. Hallo? Nein, geht nicht. Ragi-Bus-Time
hier, guck mal. Okay, ja, ich weiß, ich weiß, Puppa-Terra-Humor und so, ja, null. Weirdchamp,
Weirdchamp, Max Weirdchamp. Sind die hier schon reingejumpt oder wie? Schmeißen wir
mal einen Motion-Sensor. Mein Chef hat übrigens auch eine Meinung, was ich witzig finde zu
Battlefield 2042. Er kauft sich erst mal nicht, weil er von den ganzen Bugs abgeschreckt
ist. Ich check nicht, wo hier was ist. Ist der im Busch? Ist der im Busch? Nee. Leute,
ich check nicht, wo hier was ist dahinten. Alles klar, ich geh mal rüber und wahrscheinlich
werde von der Seite gebashed. Er will es nicht kaufen, das ist gefixtes. Was ich eine gute
Idee finde, ja. Beschleunigen wir mal kurz. Okay, wo ist der gestorben? Ist der? Sag
bloß, das wird ja schon wieder ein Hovercraft am Start. Ich hätte so irgendwie Map-Porsche
ohne Hovercrafts. Okay, okay, okay, wir stellen es uns mal. Nice. Boah ey, das Ding zieht.
Nein, Mensch, lass mich doch mal in Ruhe. Ich mach mir eine Platte rein. Platte. Schieb
dir eine Platte rein. Peng, ich retz dich. Was? Okay, vielleicht komm ich jetzt irgendwie
mit Wraps da ran. Okay, aufs Dach, aufs Dach. Ist das die Base, wo überhaupt ein Dach ist?
Nein, nein, nein. Oh, schreckt. Ich dachte, das ist die Base, wo ein Dach ist. Danke,
danke, danke. Oh, hier kommen viele. Jetzt ist RIP, jetzt ist RIP. Ich dachte, das ist
die, oh nein. Alter, der Jax ist immer noch am Start. Massive. Hier ist viel los, hier
ist viel los. Hab keinen Heal, das ist ziemlich, ein ziemlicher Pains-Champ. Ich bin zu weit
weg für meine Waffe. Da kommt was, da kommt was oder auch nicht. Ich brauch irgendeine
gute Pose, wo ich mein Crapling und so mal gescheit verwenden kann. Jetzt kommen sie,
jetzt kommen sie. Müssen wir hier weg. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Oh, wir
werden überrannt. Oh, oh. Captain Poggers, da komm ich schlechthin gerade. Nice. Ich
setze euch. Kommt's, ja. Next. Ich sehe noch nichts mal. Ist der gerade explodiert in seinen
Fallschirm? Direkt. Kannst du mal das MG mit Zweibein testen? Ich hab das Zweibein, ist
das standardmäßig unlockt? Ich glaube, das war's jetzt. Der ist gerade in seinen Fallschirm
rein explodiert. Das sah ganz, ganz merkwürdig aus. Da wird drübergeflogen. Wir brauchen
jetzt den Midi-Pan auf jeden Fall. Rein da. Eigentlich wäre mit unserer Flank-Action
so ein Schalldämpfer auch gar nicht dumm. Wie lange das Reviven braucht? Ja, das Reviven
ist mein. Wir wurden gespottet, wir wurden gespottet. Mauschen-Sensor. Okay, ich gehe
jetzt hier aufs Dach. Achtung. Oh, oh. Ich weiß nicht, wohin, ist der Typ jetzt tot
oder? Ich hab keine Ahnung, wo hier was abgeht. Oh, da kommt gleich was hoch, glaub ich. Fuck,
ich dachte mir, irgendwo kommt jetzt gleich was. Ja, das Reviven dauert zu lang. Dat
seh ich auch so. Dat is klar. LG Wilhelm. Gibt's den Kerl noch? PP29 ist broken. Ja.
Die PP29 hast mehreren Gründen broken. Du hast massig Schuss. Oh, da ist ein Gegner.
Du hast massig Schuss. Range ist gut. Du hast keinen Spread, so richtig, im Vergleich, also
kein dieser random Spreads, wie bei Assault Rifles. Nice. Aber ich will nicht immer, nicht
immer, oh fuck, das war dumm. Sag mal. Please. Alter, das Game, Mann. Wollt ihr mich verarschen
oder was? Das ist einfach straight, straight durchgeflogen. Jetzt ist, jetzt ist dat. Können
wir noch ein paar A1 rein. Commander Krieger, aber richtig. Das ist das Originale. Ich hab
mir das abgeschaut von ihm, wie das richtig funktioniert. Ich hab letztens bei ihm im
Stream reingeguckt, dass ich erst mal raus bekomme, wie das überhaupt funktioniert.
Nein. Wo sind eigentlich, wo sind, wo sind, da ist mein Teaming vorangezeigt. Ah, da,
Captain Peng ist tot. Oh. The Porgas. Warum heißt du eigentlich hier Captain Peng und
bei dem anderen Captain Porgas? Gibt's jetzt SBMM? Schwer zu sagen. Sag mal. It's my
first time. Ich bin ja gar nicht Sundance. Irgendwo, irgendwo ist hier noch was. Ich
hab hier noch was gesehen gerade. Gut, jetzt weiß ich grad nicht, wo hier noch was ist.
Da steht was, da steht was halbtotes. Hier Leute, ich komm mal zu euch rüber. Du bist
voll der Noob, du spielst gegen Level 60 Trihards. Okay. Vielleicht bist du einfach nur richtig
guter Noob und die denken. Okay. Und die denken, das muss so sein. By the way, mit der PP-Gar
25 hätte ich den ohne Probleme geowned. Wir holen mal einen Ranger. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Lass
mich in Ruhe. Ich hol dich, ich hol dich, Erx. Oh, oh, hier kommt was. Mann. Es hätte
funktionieren können. Stay back. Mal Granaten stell's. Oh, nice, nice, nice. Respawn Timer.
Jawoll, jawoll. Huge. Bin ich zwar der falsche Specialist für hier, aber besser als nix.
Oh, jetzt kommen sie. Jetzt kommen hier 50 Milliarden Gegner. Ich hör schon, ich hör
sie schon. Oh, oh. Wie die alle wissen, wo man ist, weil jeder dieses komische, dieses
dreckige Spotting macht an jeder Ecke. Kannst du Farbschema ändern? Ja, kann ich machen.
Oh, der Captain Poggers. Ach, das ist der Ranger vom Captain Poggers, der da so abgeht.
Das ist ein Pogger. Oh, oh, oh, oh. Komm an. Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.POS Ich versuch dich zu holen. Nein, nein, nein.
Mach ich nicht. Alter Falter. Das ist ja nebenbei feierlich
hier was ist dann hier los jawoll käppen poggers macht mit der pp 29 so mag ich das
beste squad hier am start halber halber s squad aber du siehst ja halt es ist es ist
mega heftig ne also es respawn es respawn eigentlich permanent gegner du kannst du
kannst nichts machen was ist mit den burst photos feuer los der ist komplett
broken der funktioniert mehr
sind hier auf dem dach oder oh oh oh käppen peng ich hole ich aber ppega squad 29
hey du musst du musst hier alle register ziehen kann nicht sein also wenn die
gegner spielen muss man das auch spielen
gucken ob wir hier rüber kommen motion sensor reinkloppen motion sensor da oben
reinkloppen da ist auf dem dach ich glaube die sind auf dem dach anderes
anderster weite na top alles alles abgescannt aber ohne am berg da steht noch
einer aber wenn ich glück habe bin ich so ein
nicer revive vielleicht kann ich den ne den kann ich nicht holen
der ist auf dem dach leute ich sag es euch das auch die heli sind am start die
heli sind am start jetzt sehen heli du draus gesprungen und ich sollte mal hier
ganz ganz schnell mich verpissen kann man hier mein mein wingsuit launchen
vielleicht das wäre zu geil vielleicht von irgendeinem das geht ja auch nicht
wenn man kann auch nicht mehr hochspringen wenn man wingsuit launchen
ja selbst der leiter im ganzen game und den holen wir jetzt den holen wir jetzt
den dude damit hat er nicht gerechnet wingsuit stellst tanze aber unsere ich
lese gleich chat ich will ich will ich will es am liebsten eigentlich jetzt
gewinnen gleich hier die runde also direkt an der base geht nein geht nicht
darf ich hier starten von or nice ich ich check nicht wo ist hier was hinter
mir hinter mir ich weiß nicht genau wo aber ich glaube es dauern die da wingsuit
von hier lauschen please lass mich rauf game nein bis game geht nicht die night
wingsuit von hier lauschen vielleicht sehr gut excellent excellent massive
massive huge huge flank flank stells hier
ok das hat sich nicht gelohnt ist zu flanken sage ich mal ganz ehrlich so wie
es ist wenn die mich abschießen dann hat es jetzt nicht das so ein komischer
ranger so ein dummer ranger monka wo sind sie denn hier kommen die von oben
getroppt oder ich check nicht wo hier was ist das sind 50 gegner dahinten ganz
schlechte idee motion sensor hin jawoll motion sensor dahin und weg hier
sportet fertig sp machen aber lass mich in ruhe zickzack rennen rüber
oh das ist anstrengend
hock aber wo ist mein team mein team ist sonst wo ich bin dumm aber das liegt
nicht an meinem team also ich ich bin dumm mein team ist richtig ich ich bin
ich bin falsch und ein pack waffe leer jetzt prägel an sich mit jeder hat für
eigentlich ähnlich ja also ich habe jetzt nicht den neuesten rechner und ich
habe leute mit einer 1090 mit einer 3090 und so gesehen die sind schlechter in
der performance aber es geht da hinten ab wir sollten zurück die nebene sein aber
die haben bloß noch sieben tickets das können wir nicht schaffen
guck mal hier wie ein peace squad am start
das wie ein peace squad ist am start so anti air granate guckt euch das mal an
hier ui mist jetzt sehen wir es nicht mehr ich muss das mehr verwenden ich
vergesse das immer wenn ich sand und spinn obwohl die so richtig geile
granaten hat ich vergesse immer die granaten zu verwenden
du hast skater granate du hast eine anti air granate
hab auf jedem server high ping hat jemanden fix ja näher an den server
ziehen ich will ich nicht schiebaten meistens kannst du nichts daran ändern
wenn du high ping hast das liegt meistens außerhalb von deinen vier wenden
es sei denn du spielst vielleicht über wlan aus dem keller mit einem balken
verbindung aber das denke ich mal nicht oder
fenster zumachen genau okoli essen fenster zumachen
corona impfen lassen für die antenne im armen dann ist das alles kein ding
ach per powerlan adapter ja das kann tatsächlich probleme machen aber dann
würde ich erst mal gucken ob du reproduzieren kannst dass das bei dir im
haus ist also könnt zum beispiel mal irgendwo unten was ich muss es wieder
zumachen als ruckel dem menü du könntest zum beispiel mal irgendwas dran
hängen auf der anderen seite vom powerlan und dann mal schauen ob wenn du
da keine ahnung wenn ich so ein raspberry pi dran oder so und pings mal
macht man in kein kein ping erzähle ich denn du machst ein eyperf dazwischen den
kisten muss die spielsuche starten haben wir doch läuft doch wenn ich hier
wieder wenn ich wir messen mit guckt sich das mal gibt es gut es war absicht
leute spiel jemand von euch halo infinite
sergeant jojo danke für den sub spiel jemand halo infinite ich habe es mir
runtergeladen aber ich habe immer noch nicht gespielt
ich hätte eigentlich mal richtig bock auf ein neues spiel was nicht verbackt
ist es fack meinte da wäre halo was es bockt aber wisst ihr was ich echt
interessant ich brauche wirklich 45 minuten bis ich halbwegs war bin jetzt
pepega ich nehme ganz so krass rein wie am anfang diese coolen sprüche immer
wohlgemerkt in der welt von battlefield 2042 gibt es hungersnöte allen menschen
geht es super schlecht aber es ist natürlich schon zeit für da mal ein
paar coole sprüche rauszuhauen halo infinite merkwürdige
zeitstellung ich hoffe nicht dass ich jetzt fliegen muss mit dem heli weil ich
hoffe der e-axe hat eingelaufen weil ich kann nicht mit dem heli fliegen wenn ich
im heli spore und heli fliegen muss dann springe ich direkt raus und dass es hier
mal anderes machen will es ich will es ja nicht du kannst fliegen ja ich spring
gleich raus du kannst dann gar nicht zwitschen falls du drinnen bist
was für musik ausmachen ihr müsst mir übrigens sagen wenn es
ruckelt im game aber im game sollte es nicht ruckeln es sollte eigentlich nur
ruckeln an ich bin ja sehr leise es sollte eigentlich nur ruckeln im lustiger
weise im ladebildschirm
da kannst du nix machen aber monka das ist aber nicht so schnell hier
haben wir hier den rüberflieger oder sind wir sind sie alter so eine century gun man
kann immer sterben blies kann er mal sterben blies und vor allem warum habe
ich ausgerechnet in dem moment meine waffe durchgeladen wo gerade ja richtig
pepega eben aber trotzdem wurde da am start den kopf raus macht man okay jetzt
auf geht's gabr mich gabr mich mache ich jetzt aber mal hier damit reingestellt
hier guckt euch an durchs fenster jetzt hier bähm so hier geht es gar nicht
weiter next ich habe die falschen attachments
doch nie dass das das nie sieht gut aus
erst mal nur in dem aufstehen muss ja wissen weil muss ja wissen was ihr
abgeht und wir können jetzt gleich wir können gleich mal gucken ob wir den
irgendwie hitten auch da hinten war doch gerade was 29 am start
ok nice platten plattors aber platter am start ich mag platten ich sag euch ich
sag es euch ehrlich ich finde es verwirrend oh shit ich finde es
verwirrend dass die leute keine gleich also nicht die ähnliche time to kill
hatten jetzt ja hast du schon recht eigentlich ziemlich am pence jam
wo denn wo denn kannst du nicht mal selbst mein selft geht nicht der selft
ging nicht ich habe dreimal angesetzt hat nicht reingesteckt oh nice captain
poggers am start in kombat a 2 hier ihm
wer das hart geregt mit der pp 29 ja jetzt so captain poggers ist dead no
hätten poggers muss gerätzt werden schlechte idee hier zu stehen ich weiß
jawoll beim weg jo oder leben sind sie auch
nichts wie fort
nichts wie fort so net rein hier ketch weiter
aber ich habe sogar was gehittet den lull der so im dach oder oben aber
scheinlich da pence man pence man das umdach sniper sniper gut auf dem dach
sehr gut irgendjemand planen was mich gerade da getroffen hat ich habe keine
ahnung ne das ist alles auf dem dach ja ach die sind komische die düsen die
wasserdüsen
meine güte auf akröft ne gibt es noch nicht
die gase die düse hat mich getroffen ach wir müssen ja a1 noch ich finde das
ist eines der breakthrough maps mit den schlechtesten flangen platzierung du
musst jetzt hier übers offene feld einfach rüber laufen
immerhin ich könnte fliegen aber fliegen kann man von a nach also von da nach da
aber umgedreht haben wir hier irgendwas erhoben ist nie hier drüben hat man den
kran da funktioniert das ob ich froh dass ich jetzt urlaub habe ich sage es
euch es ist nicht das gleiche nach am arbeitstag stream so und spielen wie wenn
man einfach erholt ist und den kopf frei hat und alles es macht einfachen
unterschied manchmal beneide ich so daily daily streamer aber auf der
anderen seite im gleichen maßen beneide ich sie nicht weil du musst dann halt
kontakt machen ob das willst du nicht stellt euch mal vor
ihr müsst dann auch spiele spielen auf die ihr überhaupt kein bock habt die
euch so richtig abfacken wenn die vielleicht gut ankommen oder weil es
kann ich auch oder weil es kann nichts anderes gibt oder sonst was das ist
richtig richtig pepega
ich habe das leider den kurzen lauf dran ich muss näher dran an die gegner dass
überhaupt überhaupt was da ist pence man vielleicht habe ich glück und
erfährt an mir vorbei ok der sieht mich nicht leute da sieht
mich bestimmt nicht da sieht mich nicht du kannst mich nicht sehen mensch warum
hat er mich gesehen ich hätte meine granate drauf
schmeißen soll ich depp ich hätte meine anti antifahrzeug antier granate
draufschmeißen sollen aber oder er macht es diese runde easy
heli heli jump beste
aber voll in den erst mal aber so was von
es war schon illegal fast so wo sind wir hier weiter
das ist die jetzt nicht mensch nicht blocken nicht blocken nicht blocken
game please hallo lass mich springen ich habe keine ahnung was mich alles trifft
aber ich rette es einfach mal eine runde wir haben es oder es ist eines der
schwersten basis finde ich sehr gut heli stellt man das ist finde ich eines der
schwersten basis weil es einfach so offen ist die gegner haben es aber auch
nicht gescheit gemacht normalerweise stecken sich da 64 mann auf einer flagge
krembo mwp machen das mal kurz ein bisschen den langen lachs vorne drauf
ach ja und falls jemand fragt warum ich nicht mit red dot spiele oder mit
irgendwie sowas oder sowas aus irgendwelchen gründen die ich euch nicht
richtig erklären kann weil ich weiß ich mir selbst nicht klar sind mag ich in
diesem spiel lieber iron sights weiß ich ob es noch jemand so geht hier gehen
wir jetzt hoch und machen flieger flieger action auch soll ich kann haben
oder wie ich gehe hier hoch und fliegt rüber das ist mir lieber
so wo gehen wir hin ich vermute mal vermute mal b1
oh oh oh oh leute
du siehst einen und die anderen wäschen dich krembo richtige ehrenmann ja es ist
erstaunlich wie viele ehrenmänner es in battle field gibt gibt es noch bots ja
ab und zu wirst du auch mal einsehen es ist unglaublich wie viele wirklich netten
leute es in battle field gibt ich habe vor ein paar tagen aber ich so richtig
selten dass das spiel halt hinter den erwarten zurück bleibt ja und ich habe
übelst abgelästert im spiel und was ist passiert die leute haben ich beruhigt in
game also die haben die haben erst mal erst mal ein bisschen bisschen kontra
geflammt so wie das ist habe ich zurück geflammt da habe ich zu ihnen gesagt so
alle der er oder in der ex geht ab jetzt mit dem little bird habe ich habe ich
ein bisschen bisschen zurück geflammt fucking fanboy bla bla bla und irgendwann
fragt mich der eine dann ja ok aber was hältst du davon einfach zu warten bis
gepatcht also nicht zu spielen da habe ich bin ich voll ausgerast hat mich
übertrieben über ihn aufgeregt so nach dem motto true fanboy response lull
usak so die üblichen gerichten also erst mal ein bisschen geradged und dann hat
er dann hat er drauf geantwortet ja ich sag doch nur wenn es sich so aufregt
er hat er hat es gar nicht böse gemeint hat er geantwortet
wtf wie warum antwortet er tut so nett auf mein sinnloses gefläme was ist da
los verstehe nicht oder geht die neid rein da ist die moa ab
da kommt leicht was jetzt machen wir den kurzen lauf drauf und besthen ihn
jawoll in den kopf alda motion sensor mal raushauen
fühlst du ich auch ich bin auch begeistert wie viel nette leute es gibt
hier in der battlefield community
ich möchte eigentlich da oben rein da oben rein erscheint mir eigentlich als
relativ nicer spot wenn ich jetzt noch gegner sehen würde anstatt von der
seite permanent beschoss oder ist hoffa kraft da müssen wir rein leute
jolo jolo hoffa kraft hoffa kraft hoffa kraft schelz jawoll rein da
beim next
hoffa kraft weiter geht's und jetzt voll auf den punkt drauf und alles
besthalter wenn die part wenn die wenn diese fahrzeug physik ja mitmachen
würde dann wäre ich hier schon längst raus
oho oho den müssen wir basten wo ist er hin eben war er noch da
ich werde gefahren jetzt geht's ab leute apache ist am start
apache apache apache macht es genauso gut wie er bleibt auch hängen
ok ist wieder frei
sag euch die fahrzeug physik ist wirklich echt echt eine sache physik
anders anders kann man das nicht sagen
wir müssen weg der hat mich rpg ach ja und wenn das hoffa kraft noch nicht op
genug ist passt mal auf was jetzt gleich passiert das hoffa kraft da war
irgendwas vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht kommt man irgendwie rauf
ah hier achtung achtung achtung mal ein nahkampf takedown sieht man so selten
in dem spiel
ich lese gleich chat ich will einfach nur links rum fahren hoffa kraft
komm an
ok jetzt muss ein bisschen gas geben dass der uns nicht best geben geben geben
und jetzt hier voll der wohl mehr hoffa kraft also es gibt nur eine sache die
besser ist als ein hoffa kraft es sind zwei hoffa kraft
doppel dual gachi bass hoffa kraft
ich muss weg fack rickt also das ding ist einfach nur extremst op habt ihr
glaube ich gesehen die haben wir oft haben die auf mich geschossen fünf mal
oder so jetzt mit raketen moment war da wollte ich jetzt nicht redespawn und es
war einfach es war einfach ripp für die
da müssen die granaten rein da müssen die granaten rein gebe ja jawoll bäm
ross getter der ex kennt noch getter
getter weiß nicht hat jemand overwatch gespielt von euch getter
ok denkt jetzt auch der max flipp flipp voll aus und hat eigentlich nicht
keinerlei gehirnmasse left mehr kade ich meine ich kann nicht mal normalen
deutschen satz machen ich mein was bitte schön ist das für einen satz keine
gehirnmasse left was soll das bitteschön bedeuten
warum bist du so gut geworden ab mit 36
mit 37 geht es abwärts
gehirnmasse ja das das gehirnmasse ist das was man für pfeil fett braucht
apache geht wieder geht wir steil heute muss mich muten muss gerade übelst muss
jetzt was achtung halt euch die kindern und halt euch die ordnung muss was
vulgäres sagen muss gerade übelst einfahren lassen fsk 18 stream match
auch mature audience
little bird gefahrt motion sensor reinkloppen 400 ist vielleicht ein
bisschen weit weg aber wir hauen einfach mal motion sensor vorneweg
da ist es ist hofer kraft stellse am start das ist noch viel zu weit weg das
noch viel zu weit aber hier ammobox ne medibox oho hofer kraft i can't
ja das ist verbugt sobald man den pixel in der wand liegt kann man nicht kann
man nicht wiederbeleben ich weiß nicht so genau von wo hier was
abgeht wenn ich ehrlich bin aber ich nehme mich mal hin und schiebe man
stift in armen covid covid erst mal machen wir müssen jetzt in die
clusterfuck rein da kann man nicht kann man nicht safe genug sein wo ist er denn
achter alle wir sollen das checken nein hofer kraft aufhören aufhören
aufhören hört auf hört auf ich leg mich jetzt in bush leg mich jetzt in busch
und heil mich so im busch sieht mich keiner
spam spam anti-act granate du hast recht ich vergesse immer auf die anti-act
Granate zu switchen
Es hat ein bisschen Klang hier darauf zu switchen ist aber keiner mehr da
Hallo game
Warum hat ihn keiner gesehen
Der war der lag einfach so hier
Bäm Parts disabled so so muss das sein hovercraft
Das hovercraft ist für
Nein, das man sollte man sollte nicht vielleicht führerlos sagen vielleicht sollte man sagen er fahrerlos da kann man das nämlich abgreifen
Gibt es ein video oder settings zu max ja guck mal heute auf youtube da habe ich zumindest das wichtigste fürs aiming gezeigt
Lousy
Haben wir noch einen motion sensor ansonsten ich zeig dir meine settings gleich nach der runde chat erinnere mich mal please da dran dass ich das mache
Wo sind meine leute denn ich habe ein korgas geht ab der er ist hovercraft oh
Jawohl jetzt ist vorbei jetzt ist vorbei instant win
instant win leute soll ich euch mal was sagen
Und auch an die anderen beiden falls sie im stream sind irgendwie zuhören es macht dem squad einfach 3000 mal mehr spaß das game man ist
Man ist nicht allein sich aufzuregen jetzt geht es rein
Es wird rein gefahren hier in das dock
Ich sehe aber nichts ich krass rein gefahren
Was willst du da machen der panzer direkt vor der nass warum es zwei verschiedene fps anzeigen sind das hier ist die in-game anzeige von
battlefield 2042 und das ist das origin overlay ich gehe mal im ex rein also ich kann auch raus denn du willst bestimmt selbst
kann an was in der hinten ich gehe raus gar nicht kann es ruhig selbst kann an das ist eigentlich das ist eigentlich viel
nicer wenn man selbst kann hat
Rauf da rüber rüber und dann komplett rauf deswegen mag ich das ist halt richtig
nice hier so mobility hätten wir bei anderen heroes auch gerne müssen aber schauen dass wir nicht
weggeklatscht werden von da vorne hier ist ja noch ein bisschen bisschen deckung wenn das jumpen
funktionieren wird wov massive ratchet rektor motion balls dass man wenigstens sieht ob wir machen es krieg action krieg
massive krieg nein das war blöd da rein zu kriegen kommen wir mal raus ich komme mal raus die kann ich
rückwärts kriechen oder schneider guckt mich komplett an und jetzt aber nichts wie weg man
nix wie weg die kann ich rückwärts kriechen das hat man frankreich nicht gelernt die kriege nur
vorwärts jetzt so ich probiere mal den big brain move ich habe keine ahnung ob der funktioniert
aber ich probiere immer ok das war nicht der big brain move ich wollte eigentlich außen rum
fliegen und hinten wieder drauf fliegen ich dachte mir das geht vielleicht wo ich werde gerätzt
danke danke nein was leute ich habe aufgehört zu schießen weil ich gedacht habe der ist dauernd
aber es war nur crack in der panzerplatte ok da liegt nichts mehr drunter
ok jetzt jetzt probiere ich den big brain move lens flare effekte auch wieder schön am start ok
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt probiere ich den big brain move wahrscheinlich funktioniert
nicht nein ich bin zu tief ich bin zu tief viel zu tief es hat nicht funktioniert aber hier ist auch
nice nice gg oh shit so spät hängen rüdiger keine kapriolen an den seiten des schiffs kann man
perfekt die ganze zeit ja ich glaube du musst fliegen an so eine zipp line wieder hoch und
wieder runter hat man die revive animation sieht richtig holzig aus ja die sieht nicht
nur holzig aus die ist vor allem viel zu lang auch wir haben es ja nice geht gleich auf
keine kapriolen rüdiger hier jetzt wird gegunnert gunner champ ganzhemp.org oder chat
wollte uns gerade bashen kann das sein ja ich habe es noch nicht so ganz raus mit dem wingsuit
wie man das am besten momentumäßig und alles handelt postchamp postchamp
ist er noch was gesporn gerade an dem gleichen spot da oben sitzen sie drauf guck mal da da
hier rein da rein da so muss das sein
ich hoffe halt nur als unabhängig von meiner enttäuschung über das game aber ich hoffe halt
dass sie noch was einbauen werden und nicht den support instant droppen die sterben weil
es sich weil es vielleicht floppt das wäre ziemlich blöd wenn das der fall wäre das
sind wahrscheinlich eh nur sand ins antiairgranaten und wo kommt denn das ist das gegner heli
hinter uns aber der ist dauernd der ist abgestürzt so wie es gerade aussieht wurde schon irgendjemand
von euch mal repaert also engineer repaert meine ich also ich legit noch nie ich weiß
gar nicht ob das in dem spiel überhaupt drin ist in der beta also es ist drinne aber ich
wurde noch nie das haben sie rausgenommen nee du hast ein repair tool oder ich weiß
es jetzt gab die mutter hast du ein repaertool doch klar klar da sind sie da da hier da
müssen sie da muss rein rein hier jetzt bräuchten wir ein paar xp geier sniper die alle spotten
für uns doch mega schnell gibt es noch irgendwelche glitches oder was gibt es noch irgendwas mit
reppen während man drinne sitzt das stimmt nicht sterben nicht wir fliegen jetzt fliegen
ein bisschen kreis wir brauchen bisschen entspannung da hätten wir richtig krass reinklatschen
können hier fast die werden jetzt gebashed aber sowas von oder auch nicht wir wurden
gehackermant hexor am start so sieht das 2042 aus da werden auch helis
gehackt gut ich meine es immer noch immer noch besser als in overwatch wo du personen
hex ich mir auch denke was zum ließ einfach mal sterben mann panzerplan der sound ist
nice ein bisschen wuchtig da könnte es schon noch sein wird hier umgependelt ich schaue
mal kurz raus hallo ich möchte nach oben fliegen nein aber das spiel will nicht dass man nach
oben fliegt vielleicht habe ich glück und darf hierauf und von da fliegen
ppega oh dumme idee hallo sehr viel die den overwatch haben schon die neuer links von
ihnen mask wahrscheinlich aber keinerlei sinnvolle erklärung gehabt warum das geht aber es war
eine gute runde gd aber nein nein nein nein nein kein ins keine zumal dass ihr nur das
eigene team sieht guck mal hier richtig erst das quad richtig gut reingeklatscht fett revives
gemacht assist gemacht kills gemacht wie 100 kills insgesamt nicht schlecht jetzt kann
ich die settings zeigen danke chat fürs erinnern nachdem wir uns jetzt angeguckt haben wie
geil wir gewesen sind die runde ja ok dann zeige ich mal die settings ich sage nicht
dass es die besten settings der welt sind gleich dabei es gibt bestimmt welche haben
es viel besser analysiert was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe zum größten teil das gemacht
was er lost in seinem video gezeigt hat ich hatte das schon mehr oder weniger was er lost
in seinem video gezeigt hat also das hier lost er heißt ja er heißt ja mittlerweile
heißt er lost dann ganz gutes settings video gemacht ich habe ein paar sachen mittlerweile
noch anders irgendwas hier mit settings pro guide fps ich glaube ich glaube hier das
sind zum größten teil die settings ich habe bloß dass ich die graphics settings so ein
bisschen anders eingestellt habe es ruckelt jetzt aber das ist liegt nicht am stream das
liegt am game weil das in den pausen ich muss play drücken weil das eben in den pausen ruckelt
warum auch immer also options was ich gemacht habe ist ich habe es auf borderless gestellt
weil es aus irgendwelchen gründen ich verstehe nicht warum normalerweise ist fullscreen
immer besser aber in diesem spiel ist aus gründen die wahrscheinlich nicht mal dies
kennt danke game ist für mich zumindest borderless besser ich kann es euch gleich weiter zeigen
während das spiel lädt renewal ich hoffe attacke hoffentlich attacke da macht es im
squad wahrscheinlich sogar richtig spaß so nein ich will einfach nur meine settings zeigen
wie kannst du so viele tabs offen haben ich habe 32 gigabyte ram das ist kein problem
oder 16 gigabyte sekunde leute vielleicht bin ich verwirrt ich habe wie viel ram habe
ich 32 ok weil ich 32 g ram habe das ist kein ist kein ding ich möchte ich möchte einfach
nur in meiner einstellung spiel wenn das wenn das gestartet ist dass ich die graphics settings
zeigen kann also was ich gemacht habe ich wie gesagt borderless aus irgendwelchen gründen
klappt das besser ich weiß nicht warum keine ahnung so das hier ist alles standard motion
blur aus film crane aus vignette wie man aus chromatik aus da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher
was es ist das on hab ich glaube das ist dass die sonne blendet oder ich glaube dass das
die sonne blendet for spawn beste und graphics settings habe ich ich kürze es mal ab graphics
settings habe ich alles auf low außer textur und textur filter so was haben wir hier pepega
29 aber wir sind attacker sehr schön sehr schön sehr schön übrigens manchmal ist
mein rennen verbackt am anfang der runde dass man aus irgendwelchen gründen nicht schneller
rennen kann jetzt gibt es wieder muss man muss man nicht verstehen oh man das nicht
warum ist das nicht reingegangen jetzt jumpen wir mal hier rein und beschen die falls sie
noch lebt aber noch mehr man es ist wieder der mit der shotgun es ist wieder der der
nicht hinguckt da wurde nicht hingeguckt hast dazu dazu muss jetzt einfach sagen hier der
hier das so richtig hi hi kacquait kacquait kacquait kacquait okay ich verliere wieder
jegliche gehörnmasse grad future frame rendering aus aus zeit mal fof 80 oh guck mal da war
es nie los in combat das captain poggers nieder der tilt man der tilt man fliegt rüber der
tiltet quasi der ist richtig am tilten der ok ist tot also das tilten ist also schräglage
vielleicht kann ich mal mehr aus dem heli springen achtscher fof ob wir machen jetzt
was wir spüren ersten sich richtig genommen zweitens die andere mich gebashed man kann
es mal probieren man kann es ja mal probieren aber das war glaube ich das war glaube ich
zu obvious dass ich da rausspringe mit der ppega 29 wäre das kein problem gewesen das
hat super funktioniert ja nice hat das funktioniert sehr sehr nice warum ist eigentlich der chat
zensiert kann man das irgendwie ausstellen ich habe keine ahnung was meine teammates
schreiben und es sind bestimmt keine schimpfwörter ich bin abge- alter game lass mich einsteigen
du willst das lernen ja ich mach demnächst tutorial hier nee patreon only video how to
macht den geilen ppega trick oh nein ich bin rausgejumpft ich stepp
ich wollte ihn killen ich hab nicht gedacht dass der ex den jetzt road killt
boah mir wird schlecht ein demo spaschen die muss spaschen die muss gebasht werden
das coole am hovercraft ist man kann aus dem gunner raus und danach schwach sind man kann
aus dem fahrer häuschen in gunner und zurück das ist mega op das ist einfach ultra nice
leider habe ich mein momentum so ein bisschen nicht nicht gejusst weil ich gegen das hovercraft
geklitscht bin guck mal der captain wer fliegt denn hier
ok das überlebe ich auch immer so kein problem ich tropf ich tropf aus dem heli raus und
ich weiß gar nicht von wo auf da oben ist ein hovercraft am start no das ist aber schlecht
granate anti antivehikel granate jawoll gib ihm gib ihm ok er hat mir gegeben das hovercraft
ist 10 von 10 das ist glaube das hovercraft aber nice nice nice hat er explodiert ich
glaube das hovercraft ist eines der opesten sachen die es in diesem spiel aktuell so gibt
es in diesem spiel aktuell so gibt es in diesem spiel aktuell so gibt es in diesem spiel
aktuell so gibt es in diesem spiel aktuell so gibt es in diesem spiel aktuell so gibt
Was hält der Typ aus? Der hat gerade wie viel? Der hat gerade 5, 6, 30 Millimeter gefressen oder so?
Schieflage. Weiß übrigens gar nicht, wie viel man hier schießen darf.
Hallo, sterben? Sterben? Sterben?
Das Hovercraft muss gebashed werden. Aber da sind schon zwei Hovercrafts von uns.
Da liegt noch einer. Guck mal, da liegt er. Was die aushalten, man. Ich glaube,
das liegt daran, dass es ein bisschen streut. Oh, da hinten rein. Jawoll. War das ein Headshot?
Wollte uns der Chat gerade rammen? Hovercraft Dude gekillt, nice. Bis 22 Uhr darfst du ruhig,
ja bis 22 Uhr bleibe ich auch da. Zumal ich jetzt Urlaub habe. Ich muss nicht mehr arbeiten gehen
dieses Jahr. Und außerdem machen wir gerade sehr entspanntes Gunner Gameplay. Da brauchst du nicht
viel Gehirnpower für. Leider, leider überhitzt und leider werden wir gerade sowas von Anti-Earth,
aber der E-Ax hat es drauf. Der kann es einfach. Guckt es euch an, der kann es. Er hat es drauf.
Okay, auf irgendwelche Gründe war es getroffen. Ah, nice, nice, nice. Alles klar. Obvious,
dass das hittet. Ich glaube, der ist down. Als Gammar immer schön das Point und Click. Ja,
muss so sein. Also wir sollten gleich erst das Squad sein, hoffe ich mal. Oh, es spart wenigstens
etwas Gehirnressourcen, wenn man Gann hat. Ansonsten ist es immer so anstrengend. Ganner kannst
er eigentlich abschalten und Point und Click. Wie targeten die uns bitte schön gerade? Der ist
quasi schon unter der Düne. Oh, ich gucke, ob ich den Chat hitten kann. Ich glaube, Chat
hitten ist als Ganner ein Ding der Unmöglichkeit. Ich glaube, das funktioniert nicht. Ich kann
mal irgendwie die Richtung halten, aber das kannst du klicken. Das kannst du nicht klicken.
Der lässt uns, der Chat lässt uns nicht in Ruhe. Okay, RIP. Zu 57. Gatchibas, Downsindfir.
Warum haben wir das nicht eingenommen bekommen? Direkt ins Hovercraft rein und weiter geht's.
The Tiltman. Ich gehe aber raus. The Tiltman. Okay, weiter. Das war ja nice. Obvius, dass
der da liegt, hätte ich mit rechnen müssen. Mehr Hovercrafts. Ja, sehr schön, sehr schön.
Okay, da machst du nichts. Irgendwann ist es auch mal leer. Es gibt Leute, die spielen
seit Battlefield 2 nichts anderes als Chat. Wobei man halt fairerweise sagen muss, das
ist nicht so wild, weil in dem Fall ist es halt so, hier spielt sich der Chat schon komplett
anders. Wir werfen mal kurz auf den da hinten was. Nein, nein, nein, nein. Hallo, ich möchte
gerne werfen. Ich darf das Ding nicht werfen. Ach, die Dinger haben Einzel-Cooldown oder
was? Obvius, dass da einer liegt, hätte ich auch wissen müssen. Sind wir uns einig,
oder? Es hätte man schon sehen können, dass da einer liegt. Vollkommen klar. Da liegt
er irgendwo, irgendwo hier liegt er, alles klar. Safe, natürlich safe. Sag mal, warum
kriegen wir Alpha 2 nicht? Okay, rüber. Der Tiltman. Tiltman. Tiltman, ich retz dich.
Tiltman. Nice Tiltman, sehr gut. Borschen-Sensor. Aha, da hinten ist er. Da hinten, da hinten
stellt er den. Nice. Oh, der Tiltman ist wieder down. Oh nee, habe ich den Revive-Bug?
Please, nicht den Revive-Bug jetzt. Das wäre jetzt fatal. Nee, nee, nee. Oh, Glück gehabt,
Glück gehabt. Wir haben es gleich, Leute, wir haben es gleich. Ich muss rein hier, rein
hier. Rein da. Nein. Okay, vielleicht kommen wir da irgendwie schnell hin. Haben wir ein
Auto oder so? Jawoll, in das Auto rein, volle Pulle. Gib ihm, gib ihm, gib alles. Gib alles.
A2. A2. Halo-Style. Erinnert das noch jemand mega an Halo, die Autos so? Alter, clusterfuck.
Peppen-Poggers. Pepega-29, so magisch das. Die müssen ihre eigene Medizin abkriegen.
Pepega-29, this is the way. Da way, da way. Das Meme ist auch dead, das benutzt niemand
mehr. Da lag ein Lachs drauf. Man kann übrigens diese Schneiber-Dinger abschießen, was eigentlich
ziemlich sinnvoll ist, aber niemals jemand macht. Seriously. Aber wir sind für den Richt-Poggers-Squad
unterwegs. Okay, jetzt, jetzt aber, jetzt, jetzt kriegen sie es. Jetzt kriegen sie es
dick. Jetzt kriegen sie es dick. Pepe-Fat kriegen sie es jetzt. Ich stelle es mich weg,
so als wäre hier nichts. Pepe-29. Was sonst? Dagegen, da müssen wir jetzt gegenhalten,
Leute. Da müssen wir jetzt gegenhalten, es hilft nichts, es ist Zeit. Es ist Zeit. Oh,
nice, kann ich hier rein? Was? Nicht genug Platz zum Deployen? Game. In Combat? Ja,
er wird von mir beschossen gerade und wahrscheinlich ist er gleich dead, aber vielleicht auch die
richtig big brain spawn-Platz, nein, er ist dead. Da vielleicht? Da vielleicht? Ah,
sehr gut. Okay, Pepega-29 am Start. Und jetzt bräuchte man, jetzt bräuchte man Smoke-Granaten.
Smoke-Granaten wäre noch mal richtig, richtig nice, dass man hier rüberkommt. Okay. Alter,
guck mal, seht ihr, seht ihr, wie offen und flach das ist? Wie, wie um alles in der Welt
hat man sich das hier vorgestellt? Wie, wie, wie genau, wie genau soll das jetzt funktionieren?
Ja, wir haben welche auf dem Dach, das ist schon mal sehr gut. Vielleicht schaffe ich's,
vielleicht schaffe ich's rüber. Pepega-29, hier, hier liegen sie schon rum. Nein, ihr
könnt mich nicht hitten, das ist unmöglich. Oh fuck, da stehen ja auch 75 Gegner. Shit.
Okay, wenn ich Glück habe, nee, der ist nicht dead. Mist, der ist nicht dead. Da machst
du nichts. Pepega-29, vielleicht, komm mal, da kommen welche, da kommen welche, da kommen
welche. Jawoll, jawoll, gib mir. Oh, Brit, Brit, Poggers Brit. MVP, Ehrenfrau Brit. Es ist
einfach zu viel, mann. Es ist einfach zu viel. Ah, ah, ah, Hans-Man. Jawoll, weg Pepega, Pepega-29.
Guck mal, habt ihr gesehen, wie er evaded ist? Aua. Wie er abgehauen ist, einfach nur weil
er diese Anti-Dingsnade gekriegt hat. Pepega-29, Leute, ich sag euch. Pepega-29, Leute, ist
der Chat kaputt oder schreibt grad keiner was? Ironside-Main, ja. Ich weiß, ich kann's nicht
erklären, warum, aber ich mag die Ironsides in dem Game. Ich versteh nicht, warum, aber
ich spiel am liebsten Ironsides. Ihr seid da? Gut. Ja, war grad zu wenig los. Der Chat ist
schon badge. Ist ja auch schon spät. Sind wir uns glaub ich einig, oder, dass es schon
spät ist? Oder ist schon spät, erst 22 Uhr? Oh, oh. Brauchst du nen Sensor hin? Bunker!
Die Nate kommt aber gut, glaub ich. Oh, nice. Ah, nur Equipment. Nur Equipment zerstört.
Ich glaub, wir sollten den Point gleich haben. Ja, ja, ja. Das sieht doch gut aus. Das sieht
doch gut aus. Guck mal, hier einfach wieder bestes Squad. Bestes Squad. Da flankt was?
Nein, nein, nein. Aufhören zu flanken. Ist die oben? Ist die oben? Stoppt schon down.
Pepega 29. Ich sag's euch. Ach, wir haben es schon eingenommen. So, Nate, da stehen sie.
Ich weiß, dass sie da stehen. Guck, die brauchen uns hier. Die brauchen uns. Erster Kill, gleich
Motion Sensor. Ah, mein Motion Sensor ist dead. Hier ist Sundance halt richtig gut, wenn man
die Granaten hier durchspammen kann. Hä? Kann es sein, dass die auf dem Dach sind?
Die Granate kommt gut. Nein, nein, nein. Ich hab's doch gesehen, dass es C4 ist. War
das jetzt... Sorry, sorry, sorry. C5. Natürlich. Natürlich C5. In der Zukunft verwendet man
kein C4 mehr. Das ist outdated. Overrated. Jebaited. Ich hab keine Ahnung von, wo mich
was hättet. Frack? Krass. Game gut jetzt? Um ehrlich zu sein, nö. C4 ist bloated. C5
ist jetzt angesagt, ja. Nee, das Spiel ist einfach unfertig. Das wurde mitten aus dem
Entwicklungsprozess gerissen. Ah, nice. C2. Pongas. Ich will raus. Okay, sehr gut Spiel.
Sehr gut. Sehr, sehr gut. Genau in diese Richtung wollte ich. In diese Richtung und
nicht anders. Okay. Oh, oh. Ganz, ganz dumme Idee. Ppega 29, Leute. Ppega 29.
The way. Ppega 29. Was willst du denn dazu sagen? Oh, da kommt ein Gegner. Oh, das ist
die One-Hit-Sniper, oder? Das ist die One-Hit-Sniper. Sag mir, das ist die One-Hit-Sniper. Ich,
ich check's immer noch nicht, was die One-Hit-Sniper ist. Es gibt auf jeden Fall ne One-Hit-Sniper.
Okay, One-Hit-Sniper ist, One-Hit-Sniper ist übertrieben. Es ist keine richtige One-Hit-Sniper.
Es ist eine Sniper, die auf Bodyshot, also nee, auf, auf upper, upper Bodyshot one-shotted.
Kopf über. Okay, ich werd gleich wieder rausspringen. Ich glaub, man kann hochfliegen, dann kann
man cancelen und dann kann man wieder aufmachen. Dann kann man cancelen und dann kann man wieder
aufmachen. Na, so ganz funktioniert das nicht, wie ich's mir gedacht hab. Hochfliegen, cancelen,
wieder aufmachen. Das geht irgendwie so. So machen das die ganzen, so machen das die ganzen
Wingsuit-Pros. Nein. Ice Equipment. Oh, da ist Schneiber, Schneiber. Oh, da oben ist
einer. Und da ist nicht nur einer, da sind noch viel mehr. Versuch mal oben da irgendwie
ein Nade drauf zu schmallen. Da kommt gleich was von rechts. Noch mehr. Nein. Oh, Pepega
29, Mann. So geht das, Pepega 29. Da machst du wenigstens was, da geht wenigstens was rein
mit dem Ding. Da geht wenigstens was rein. Ich find übrigens die letzte Base ist richtig
schwierig hier. Oh nee, was ist hier los? Was, was, was erlauben die sich das einfach
zu capturen, man? Okay, das beste was ich machen kann ist einfach warten, bis Leute
bei mir gesponsert sind. Und Enemys spotten. Enemys spotten und warten, bis Leute bei mir
gesponsert sind. Pepega 29, Mann.
Shit, da war hinten ja noch einer, den hab ich nicht gesehen. Aber wir sind schon wieder
am Start, wir sind schon wieder am Start. Jetzt, jetzt geht's, jetzt geht's. Oh, Power
Gas, Power Gas. Oh, oh. Nice, sehr gut. Sehr gut, Game. Aber gut, da kann das Game jetzt
nichts dafür, ne? Aber hier geht's rein, hier geht's rein. Vielleicht, ah nee, noch
ein Revive geht nicht. Aber wir, guck mal, wir drücken da jetzt so gut rüber, wenn wir
jetzt die zwei nicht verlieren, kriegen wir's wahrscheinlich. Gehen wir mal hier rein.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh. Ich dachte, wir springen jetzt raus. Die haben's bestimmt
nicht gecheckt bei diesem riesen Hovercraft hinter ihnen. Da, was, was, was soll schon
passieren? Wir haben's, wir haben's, Pogu. Jax, du kannst ruhig gleich selbst gunnern,
ne? Also ich will dir den Gunner-Slot hier nicht wegnehmen. Weil, ich find das, ich
find das Hovercraft gerade richtig gut, wenn man, oh, Monkey S. Find es grad gut, wenn
man selbst gunnern kann, dann ist es richtig nice. Aber seht ihr, das Hovercraft heilt
sich selbst? Das find ich halt, das find ich halt schon krass, dass das Hovercraft sich
selbst heilt. Ich mein, das Ding ist mega-OP, aber heilt sich auch noch selbst. Ah, shit.
Da, da fehlt's, da fehlt's dem 37-jährigen Boomer einfach am krassen Flick-Aim. Aber
Eax hat's schon gemacht, jawoll. Unser Hovercraft ist noch da. Unser Hovercraft ist wahrscheinlich
bald nicht mehr da. Okay. Die sind einfach zu schnell, ja? Aber geht trotzdem. Geht
trotzdem ganz gut. Okay. Alles klar. Wir sind hinter dem Panzer, das ist glaub ich eine
not so good position, da zu sein. Oh, Monkey S. Oh, oh. Ja, dead. Der Panzer, der hat es
ja schon, der hat uns schon angelacht. Ich hab den Typ im Cockpit sitzen sehen, oh alter,
free kill, free kill. Und hat's ihm direkt angesehen. Oh nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Wingsuit, please, was ist los mit dir, man? Okay. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was gerade passiert
ist. Wo ist hier was? Vertikales Gameplay. Shotgun. Wer spielt in diesem Spiel Shotgun?
In diesem Spiel spielt niemand Shotgun, außer dieser eine Typ, der jetzt mich in diesem
Treppenhaus wegpumsen will damit. Niemand spielt Shotgun, alter. Was ist das? Oh, wir
sind dead. Nice, da muss ich rein. Da gehen wir rein, da sind wir drin. Da sehen wir nichts,
aber ich hab ja ein Wingsuit am Start. Wenn ich wüsste, wo oben und unten ist, dann
könnte ich auch irgendwie mich hier durchstelsen. Okay, nice, da gingen wir schon hin. Vielleicht
kommen wir hier rein? Nee, shit. Ah, wir Pegaflying Skills. Was ist hier los? Das ist mir zu hoch.
Ist hier was drin? Ich check es wirklich nicht, ich hab keine Ahnung, wo die sind überhaupt.
Wo? Killcam. Okay. Die übrigens, ich hab es ja gerade gesagt, ich finde, das ist mit
die schwerste Base hier. Also das Haus einzunehmen, finde ich wirklich nicht so easy. Wo sind
wir? Ich bin am Ende meines Mousepads angelangt. Alter, meine Boomerhand ist überfordert.
Zu viel auf einmal. Rekt, vorbei. Ja, Boomerhand ist zu viel. Ich war mit meiner Maus schon
vom Mousepad runter gerade. So viel muss man da nachziehen. Aua. Hallo, Sunnins, heilst
du dich mal? Danke, nice, GG. Sehr gut gemacht. Du hast eine Heal-Pen verwendet. Eine Runde
Motion Sensor. Okay, was geht hier? Geht hier überhaupt was? CP-Gar 29 geht hier. CP-Gar
29. Okay, ich krieche jetzt nur noch. Da ist ein gegnerischer Ranger. Hallo? Game, please.
Noch mal Motion Sensor. Jetzt aber. Die sind bestimmt hier drin. Okay, nice. Boah. Boah,
da kommen noch mehr gleich. Shit, rekt. Oh, da kommen noch mehr. Ich hoffe, er rettet
mich nicht, weil dann bin ich dead. Ganz im Magazin in den Baum geholzt. Ja, aber man
hat ja den Kopf von der Durchschimmern sehen. Deswegen habe ich nicht verstanden, warum
das? Warum da gar nichts? 120 plus KD, muss sein. Face Bewerbung ist raus. Was ist denn
gerade angesagt? Ist Face Clan überhaupt noch in? Bei was bewirbt man sich denn heute
als richtig krasser Quickscoper? Hey, sind bestimmt nicht mal angesagt. Was ist heute?
Bestimmt irgendwas, was ich noch nicht gehört habe. Okay, durchsliden, durchsliden. Poggers.
Oh, da sind Gegner drinne. Ja, ja, ja. Bäm. Kaputt gehen. Damage nehmen. Sehr gut. Ich
will da nicht rein. Herr Poggers, jetzt aber. Okay, nein, ging nicht. Denied by game logic.
Die stehen doch da noch. Da ist ein Overcraft davor. Da ist halt ganz viel Drama gerade
wegen Krypto Scams. Ach ja. Wer scammt da? Ich meine, die sind immer noch bei Krypto
Scams und nicht bei Krypto NFT Spams. Das kann man ja noch. Kann man ja noch aufrüsten.
Okay, ich sollte als Webster, ich sollte Webster rein spawnen und da hoch gehen. Einfach easy
easy Mod. Wo kommt man denn hier raus? Hier bin ich ja noch nie durch. Wollt ihr mir
sagen Battlefield 2042 Maps haben Flanks? Seriously? Was ist denn das? Das ist ja.
Was soll ich denn dazu sagen? Ich kann es ja kaum glauben. Aber natürlich ist da jemand
und natürlich auch einer von der Seite. Captain Poggers ist auch dead. Der mich da gekillt
hat, war übrigens nicht der links von oben. Das war noch ein Dritter. Respawn, Respawn.
Wings Danger Gangster. Alter Wingsuit, come on. Oh da wäre ich gekillt, wenn ich hier hoch
kletter. Das ist easy target, easy target. Richtig easy target. Easiestarget. DPK 29.
Mal kurz hier eine Runde. Machen wir mal die Gun weg. Sollen wir nur gucken, dass da nichts
runterkommt. Oh der Motion Sensor. Guckt euch das mal an. Boah die lassen sich wegspringen.
Runde rein. What the fuck? Was zum? Was war ich denn hier sehend jetzt? Natürlich von
der Seite, wo sonst? Was war denn das gerade? Wie bin ich denn dadurch? Klippt? Verstehe
ich. Also Leute, warum sind wir nicht Top Squad? Hier gehts rein man. 50, 46. Was soll
man sonst noch machen? Okay, wir haben die eins fast. Fast eingenommen. Gib mal Gas mit
deinem Wingsuit. Oh oh, da oben. Das war übrigens by the way. Das war absolut nicht
gewollt. Ich bin einfach zu pepega mit diesem Wingsuit zu fliegen. Was ihr gerade gesehen
habt. Also ich bin einfach nicht in der Lage, auf diesem Dach zu landen. Oh ganz schlecht.
Mann, hier gehts ab. Ist hier was? Ist hier nichts? Ist hier was? Hier fliegen einfach
Leute in die Luft. Pepega. Das ist mir zu vertikal. Da setzt mein Kopf aus. Richtig
vorbei. Das ist komplett durch. Ich nehm mal den Crapling Hook mit. Kann das mal aufhören?
Man dem immer so nen Trall nach hinten zu geben. Okay. Peace Game, funktionier doch einfach.
Es ist egal wo ich hingrücke. Ich werd gefickt. Sags euch von der Seite. Da ist er schon.
Nee. Ich muss hier weg. Ranger, nee nee nee Ranger. Lass mich nur kurz hier oben raus
gucken. Ich wusste es Leute. Habt ihrs gesehen? Ich wusste es einfach. Ich wusste es einfach
dass der da unten ist. Wenn sich fragt was ich mache, ich teste ob ich Burst an hab,
weil Burst das beste ist. Wenn man trifft, ist Burst das beste. Wenn man so dumm ist
wie ich und vorbeischießt, dann ist Burst nicht so gut. Aber im Nahkampf finde ich Burst
von dieser Pistole ist echt das beste. Also du killst, also du killst ziemlich sicher
mit einem Burst in den Kopf. Was das jetzt nicht war, das war ja vielleicht die Hüfte
oder so. Wobei Maria Falck ist wahrscheinlich schon auch jenseits der 60, so nen Schuss
in die Hüfte. Jeder kennt die Storys von der Oma und der Hüfte. Das ist wahrscheinlich
besser als irgendwie ein Headshot oder so. Oh, Stellsweg. Stellsweg. Nice GG. Fuck,
kommt manchmal vor. Ok. Nein, wir haben verloren. Wir haben verloren. Nope. No Pass. Aber unser
Squad war richtig gut. Komm Leute, eine Runde machen wir noch. Was sagst du zur Grafik
zum Game besser, schlechter als die Vorgänger? Ähm, grafisch, also vom Unterbau her würde
ich sagen, es ist gar nicht schlecht, es ist ähnlich gut wie Battlefield 5, aber den Maps
fehlt oder generell dem Spiel fehlen halt einfach die Hingucker. Das ist halt wie gesagt
komplettes Spiel aus der Entwicklung gerissen. Laut Patchnotes ist so vieles gefixt, aber
was weiß ich den Patchnote schreiben. So eine machen wir noch Leute. Nicht wundern, dass
es jetzt ruckelt, das ist nur im Menü. Bis 12. Was ist euch los? Bis 12. Ihr wisst was
ab 22 Uhr ist, oder? Ab 22 Uhr ist schon spät. Genau. Wie gut ist der Day 1 Patch? Wir gucken
uns mal. Leute, ich zeige euch jetzt während wir auf der Suche nach dem Game, ich zeige
euch die Patchnotes. Sucht der eigentlich jetzt? Ah ne, der sucht gar nicht. Ok, jetzt.
Battlefield Day 1 Patchnotes. Huge Patchnotes, Massive Patchnotes. Wir brauchen Link zu EA.
Wir gucken einfach Twitter, Twitter, Direct. Komm, da steht das. Also schaut euch diesen
massiven Day 1 Patch an. Haben wir den überhaupt verlinkt? Kann das sein, dass der gar nicht
drauf ist? Letzhaft. Hier, Battlefield Update 1. Update, das ist der Day 1 Patch. Update
021. Das ist alles. Und davon ist außer so diese Rubber Banding Geschichten eigentlich
nichts wirklich interessantes dabei. Also das ist alles. Das ist der Day 1 Patch, der
das in Ordnung bringt. Das Spiel ist jetzt bugfrei. Ich wollte es jetzt nicht so direkt
sagen im Chat, aber ja. Jetzt ist hier die Bombe geplatzt. Das Spiel ist jetzt bugfrei.
Wie man heute ja auch schon eindrucksvoll gesehen hat. Wir hatten heute nicht einen Bug. Chat,
ernsthaft, welchen Bug habt ihr gesehen im Stream? Also ich habe keinen gesehen. Nicht
einen. Oh, beste Map. Die ist gut, die mag ich. Die mag ich. Dann spielen wir jetzt auch
keine Pepega 29 Spiele. Oh, guck mal, wir haben eine neue SMG. Da habe ich jetzt mal
Bock drauf. Hoffentlich hat die halbwegs Schuss. Ich glaube, die hat aber nur 20 Schuss. Das
ist ziemlich Pepega, eine MP zu spielen mit 20 Schuss. Oh, ich muss mich entscheiden,
Leute. Ich werde jetzt force gespawnt. Der Player ist schuld, klar. Was sonst? Ich dachte,
das Feuer ist schuld oder wie war das? Ihr müsst mal reingucken. Sogar diese Intro-Dinger
klitschen übelst rum. Langer Lux oder kurzer Lux drauf? Ich würde sagen, hier ist ziemlich
close quarter. Jawoll. Da geht was rein und ja, eigentlich Ironside. Ich mag das Ironside.
Ich kann mir nicht helfen. Das Feuer ist schuld. Und jetzt machen wir dick XP, Leute. Wir machen
massivste XP. Wir werfen da jetzt Motion Sensor rein und das bringt dicke XP. Also das ist
die schnellste Variante, wie ihr leveln könnt in diesem Spiel. Motion Sensor dahin und
hier jetzt Motion Sensor dahin und wenn du die Gegner reinstellst. Was ist denn da hinten
los? Das hat er sich so nicht vorgestellt. Übrigens, Zäune sind undurchschießbar. Aber
ich bin noch Webster. Okay, das ist gar nicht so schlau auf hier auf die Fans. Was auch
immer. Wir können mal den Big Move probieren, ob das nicht aus ist auf der Map. Ist schon
aus auf der Map. Ja, ja, wir verlieren nämlich. Wir müssen zurück. Das ist richtig Pepega,
das wir hier vorne rumstölzen. Hardcore Pepega. Pepega 29 ist das. Hinner, auf, auf. Das
ist auch was, was ich fragwürdig finde so bei der Größe der Maps. Guckts mal, wie
lang es dauert, dass ich rüber, ja Assault-Reifen sind nicht gut. Guckts mal, wie lang es dauert,
bis ich drüben bin zum Supporten an A2. Das dauert einfach 30 Stunden. Guckts mal hier.
Das dauert viel zu lang. Na, super. Shotgun. Was ist es denn heute mit dieser Shotgun?
Ne, das sind alles Gegner. Zwei Runden Close. Ne, Conquest gespielt. Man merkt dem Game sehr
stark an, dass es innerhalb der Entwicklung einen Punkt gab, wo es ein Battle Royale war.
Ja, finde ich auch. Mit Portal. Ja gut, was die Leute mit Portal machen. Ich weiß nicht,
ob du mein Video gesehen hast zu Portal. Ich habe vor zwei, drei Tagen ein Video gemacht
zu Portal. Oh nein, nein, nein, Captain Poggers. Alter Mann, mein PP-GA-Aim gerade ist ja strong.
Was wollte ich denn jetzt sagen? Ich habe vor zwei Tagen oder drei Tagen ein Video gemacht
zum Portal. Allerdings ist das so das Maximale, was man machen kann schon. Muss mich mal anstrengen.
Ich bin so faul geworden beim Spielen. Kennt ihr das? Wenn ihr lieber langsam rüber zieht
und denkt, ach was, der läuft schon ins Fadenkreuz, anstatt einfach mal ordentlich rüber zu ziehen,
dann ärgere ich mich immer über mich selbst, wenn ich denke, Max sei nicht so faul beim
Spielen. Schon spät ist es, kann ich mich mit rausreden. Okay. Vielleicht kommen wir
irgendwie aufs Dach. Was? Das war schon wieder die Shotgun. Was ist mit den Shotgun Leuten
heute los? Nice Captain Poggers, sehr gut, sehr gut. Exquisite. Checkt irgendjemand,
wann man erkennt, ob Burst-Modus an ist und wann nicht. Oh Mann, diese wasserdichten,
schussdichten Dinger. Richtig Pepega. Der EX-Push, der push ich mit. Ach, der ist down.
Oh, Pepega aimed, Mann. Pepega aimed. Die denken, wir gehen links, wir gehen rechts
und bam, in your face. Captain Peng, ja, ja. Oh, schreckt. Okay, das haben wir aber gut
gemacht. Ich mein, also mehr hätten wir aus unseren zwei, drei Leuten im Squad wirklich
in diesem Haus gerade nicht machen können. Wie gut ist das Spiel aus deiner Sicht stand
jetzt, es ist gekaufwürdig. Moment, was? Sekunde, Sekunde. Wie gut ist da das Spiel
aus deiner Sicht stand jetzt und ist es gekaufwürdig stand jetzt? Nein. Finde ich nicht. Finde
nicht, dass es kaufwürdig ist. Aktuell. Das ist mitten aus der Entwicklung gerissen
unfertig und und nicht zu Ende gedacht. Beides. Was ist hier los? Was, Alter? Oh, war da gerade
einer von hinten am Start? Pepega 29 sicherlich. Oh, hier wird's voll. Watch out, someone's
here. Mal gucken, ob wir Glück haben. Da kommt einer. Oh, shit, das war zu viel. Alter,
das Ding kickt richtig krass rum mit der schnellen. Ich meine, ich hab den kurzen Lauf drauf
und die Close-Quarter-Munition. Das ganze, guck mal an, das Ding ist hier die reinste
Spritze hier, guck mal, guck mal. Keck wait. Warum spawn ich und es steht in hovercraft
hinter mir? Was sind deine all-time favorite maps battlefield? Ich könnte so ein paar
underrated Maps fallen mir gleich ein, so was wie Terran Highway oder so. Also Port Valdez
definitiv. Bad Company 2, Port Valdez fällt mir so hin. Das war die Beta-Map von Bad Company
2. Ich glaube, daran lag das, weil ich hab die Beta mit dem Friseur damals massiv, massiv
viel gegrindet. Okay, hier muss ich gar nicht hin. Okay, Webster sackt hier jetzt grad,
Alter, das ist so heftig. Ja klar, da springt er noch raus. Okay, ich hab halt keine großartige
Range damit. Ich sag euch gleich die Maps noch. Ja, alles klar, Game, alles klar, alles klar.
Alles klar, Game. Okay, meine Munition ist leer, GG Eats. Sag mal, was ist denn mit diesen
Gegnern los? Können die mal sterben da drüben vielleicht irgendwann? Okay, wir brauchen
erstmal einen Motion Sensor da drüben, so viel ist sicher. Und wir brauchen einen Motion
Sensor da, dass wir sehen, wenn uns einer Gatschi bassen möchte. Okay, jetzt hat's geschafft.
Fünf anläufe, jetzt hat's uns gesniped. Vielleicht kriegen wir den Rest, das wäre
natürlich Pog. Oh, die stehen direkt vor der Tür. Also Port Valdez, nee, wir hatten nicht
ganz unendlich, Muni, aber fast. Also Port Valdez. Ascension Bad Company 1 fand ich auch
richtig nice. Ist glaube ich sowas, kaum einer auf dem Schirm hat. Ich muss den langen Lachs
drauf machen, dass ich drüben eine Chance hab, da dran zu kommen. Jetzt der lange Lachs.
Okay, Zack, ich warte mal kurz. Epicenter fand ich auch mega nice, mochte keiner so
wirklich, ist aber auch underrated. Terran Highway auch richtig underrated. Noshah Canals
muss ich sagen, ist überhaupt nicht so meins, ich mag Noshah Canals nicht. Mein Gott, die
Assault Rifles, Mann. Vielleicht geht das noch irgendwie so, vielleicht gibt es noch
Leute, die sagen, Noshah Canals doch nicht beste aller Zeiten. Grand Bazaar auf jeden
Fall richtig pock. Grand Bazaar Zen Crossing. Zavod Battlefield 4, mochte ich wirklich.
My God, die Assault Rifles. Okay, Sekunde, wir machen jetzt den Big Brain Move. Haben
jetzt geswitcht auf, wir haben keine Muni mehr. Mann, kann hier mal irgendwas sterben,
ich kriege Anfälle. Da fuck, Alter. Richtig Big Brain, die Moves hier gemacht, oben auf
den Container raus, bam, bam, bam. Und ich bin nix gekillt. Heals Extremely Batman. Vielleicht
soll ich keine Assault Rifles mal spielen. So, ich will aber keine Bebega 29 spielen.
Geh mal her. Das Ding hat nur 20 Schuss, da habe ich jetzt keinen Erfrau. PBX. Okay,
was haben wir denn hier? Irgendwas. Und zack. Killverbot, ja. Nicht Tanzverbot, Killverbot
hier. Vielleicht soll ich mir auch einen Pornhub-Account erstellen, wie Tanzverboten sagen,
das heißt dann Killverbot. Und dann lade ich dann Mathe-Vorlesungen rauf. Ich habe gehört,
das ist das neueste, das ist das neueste Meta auf Pornhub. Man lädt Mathe-Vorlesungen.
Kennt ihr das? Diesen Typ der Mathe-Vorlesungen hochlehnt und es irgendwie alle lustig finden
und den voll feiern. Wahrscheinlich weiß keiner wovor ich spreche. Ah, wir sind mal
wieder in Alpha 2 drüben. Doch, okay, okay, nice. Vielleicht kann ich schnell crossen
hier rüber. Nice, okay. Dieses Game ist überall was, wo du nicht mit rechnest. Alter, mein
Hintern tut weh. Vom Sitzen. Ich weiß, was jetzt für ein Emote in den Chat kommt. Das
ist mir so klar. Chat, wenn ihr es schafft, kein Gatschi oder Hyper Gatschi oder sonst
was rein, dann bin ich stolz auf euch. Puma, sehr gut. Das finde ich besser. Das finde
ich viel besser. Oh nice, was ist hier los? Was ist hier los? Was geht hier? Was geht hier?
Nice, gecaptured. Jutschbock. Captain Poggers, Yolo Reds. MrFahrenheitFR. Da ist er, da freut
er sich. Da freut er sich. Der MrFahrenheitFR. Alarm. So, jetzt geht gerade nicht viel, oder?
Oh, was haben wir denn da? Haben wir da etwa ein Spawn Beacon? Ich würde sagen, wir brauchen
ein Motion Sensor. Ein Spawn Beacon, so, so. Ein Massive, nice Spawn Beacon. Oh nee, oh,
Captain Poggers, ich komme aus Dach gerannt. Nein, nicht sterben. Nice. Pschu, sehr gut.
Captain Poggers ist wieder am Start, dann kann nichts schief gehen. Gucken, wo die Gegner
herkommen. Ah, hier unten ist einer, irgendwo. Ich bin nicht ganz sicher, ist der hier drin?
Der muss doch hier drin sein. Eich doch. Oh klar, dass der hier drin sein muss. Wo ist
hier was? Wir haben es gleich wieder, nice. Leute, easy win. Ich sage es euch, easy ist
win auf hier unsere Battlefield Carrier. Oh, oh, ich muss weg. Ich muss weg. Das wird
mir zu viel... Yolo Rats, nein. Oh, ich dachte es den Gegner. Wer dachte noch, dass es Gegner
sind? Hat er sich da gerade reingebeamt? Der war einfach da. Boomer Augen zu langsam.
Schon spät, schon spät. Ich glaube, ich glaube von uns lebt nichts mehr. Ja, ich sage
doch, das Spiel ist richtig was für Helistelzer. Ah, das ist eine LMG. LMG legit. Oh, da fliegen
sie, da fliegen sie. Ich gehe da jetzt rein. Nee, ich gehe doch nicht rein. Den holen wir
jetzt, der wird gebashed. Ey, dieses Game hat keinen Bock auf mich. Jetzt werde ich
die 4 von irgend so einem random Typ am LKW. Nochmal rein hier. Respawn Timer Active, eine
Sekunde. Okay. Letzte Gehirnzellen sind jetzt endgültig weg. Aber ich will, dass wir gleich
die erste Base holen hier. Oh, was ist hier? Was ist hier? Bashen, alter Bashen? Ah, der
ist auf dem Kran oben, ich Noob. Denk mir alles, wo ist der denn? Der ist auf dem Kran,
der auf dem Kran stellt. Enemy Spotted, Enemy Spotted, Enemy Spotted. Ja klar, ja klar,
der stirbt nicht, ja klar. Aber wir haben es klar, ich glaube, wir kriegen es wieder,
ich glaube, wir kriegen es wieder. Erstmal Motion Sensor davor donnern. Nice, nice. Oh,
ich glaube, wir kriegen es wieder, das ist richtig gut. Den kriege ich, sag mal, was
ist mit meinem Red Dot? Warum ist denn das so mega klein? Nehmen wir mal die Iron Sides,
die sacken aber auf der Waffe. Den Red Dot erkennst du doch gar nicht richtig. Wir haben
es, komm, wir haben es gleich wieder. Nice, next. Da unten war noch einer. Oh ne, Schneiber
Dude, mit dem, mit dem lege ich mich, ach pass auf. Aufwarten, wir haben es gleich, wir
haben es gleich. Schon spät Leute, schon spät, schon spät. Schon spät, ja, easy
clap, easy clap, easy clap. Wollen wir noch eins spielen? E-Hacks, Captain Pongas, wie
sieht es aus? Wollen wir noch eine Runde spielen? Die ging ja relativ schnell. Oder, oder wollen
wir Schluss machen? Okay, eine machen wir noch. Es sei denn, es ist eine Kackmap. Schon spät,
ja, es ist spät. Erster von 36. Leider kann ich jetzt meine eigenen Stats nicht mehr angucken,
aber wir scheinen ganz gut gewesen zu sein. Leute, morgen kommt mein Fazit zu Battlefield
2042, ich hab Angst, EA wird mich nie wieder sponsoren danach. Ein Video steht noch aus,
ein Video steht noch aus, aber ich glaube, das ist vorbei. Nein, nicht das Rage Video,
ich hab das diesmal relativ sachlich aufgenommen noch. Ist das Problem mit dem Aim Assist behoben?
Gute Frage. Nächste Frage, keine Ahnung. Ich weiß nicht, ob es Aim Assist Probleme
mit Konsole gab. Ist mir nicht bekannt. Wie läuft eigentlich mein EA-Sponsored-Video?
Hä, was ist das? Alter, warum ruckelt das Video so krass? Ach, dieses Video war das
Lul. Ach so, ich weiß, warum mein Battlefield im Ladebildschirm 100% CPU-Last braucht. Battlefield,
das ist das All... Wo ist denn mein aktuelles Video? Wir gucken mal, wann wir... Ah, Orbitzels
haben wir heute noch gar nicht gespielt, sehr gut. Orbital, 10k, das dürfen die sich nicht
beschweren, ja. Da hat nicht die Welt darauf gewartet, dass ich ein Sponsored-Video mache,
das hab ich ihnen aber auch gesagt. Sponsored bei EA, aber ich freu mich, jetzt hat er das
so aufgenommen. MMX300. Maxi, woran das wohl liegen könnte? Wäre das vielleicht möglich,
dass ich versuchen muss jetzt nicht zu sagen, Leute, hier ist die 5000-stellige Buckliste
von diesem Spiel. Was stellen sich die Leute dann vor? Oh nee, Black Friday erstellt es.
Sponsor Sie gerade die Marke Kappa? Nee, Kappa ist out. Kappa HD? Allerdings, ich bin mittlerweile
schon umgestiegen auf Kappa 4K. Sekunde. Gibt es das? Kappa 4K? Das ist die Mode, muss
es doch geben, auf die Idee ist doch schon jemand anderes gekommen als ich. Es gibt
kein Kappa 4K? Interessant. Ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass es ein Kappa 4K
gibt. Ich meine, wenn es Kappa HD gibt, warum gibt es kein Kappa 4K? Gibt es dieses Jahr
auch wieder mega Black Friday Angebot? Heute ist doch Black Friday, oder? Oder nächste Woche?
Oh nee, McKay war blöd. Ach, nächste Woche? Achso. Jetzt wollen sie es aber wissen, jetzt
hier der Heli-Stell ist aber ausgebrochen. Ok, ich gehe jetzt raus. Ok, ich werde jetzt
von der Seite weggefickt, definitiv. Da ist schon der nächste, ich sehe ihn schon. Ah!
Du kannst dieses Spiel nicht kontrollieren, es geht nicht, es ist nicht möglich. Richtig
harter Gachi-Buzz, man. Richtig harter Gachi-Buzz. Ok, next. Danach kommt logischerweise Kappa
256444, korrekt. Endlich erkennt das mal jemand. Wir könnten mal, habe ich irgendeine Waffe
mit, ich glaube hier habe ich einen Silencer für. Das probieren wir jetzt mal aus, wir
machen einen Stells-Modus. Äh, äh. Stells-Modus. Wird nichts bringen, weil irgendwie alles
gespottet wird wie verrückt, aber wir können es ja mal probieren. Der Jax hier wieder
richtig, haule richtig rein mit dem Little Bird. Wird bald zwei Wochen vor dem Black
Friday geben, weil heute schon Early Black Friday ist. Es ist Black Friday im Monat oder
beziehungsweise Black Friday Quartal mittlerweile ja schon. Ok, komm, wir machen YOLO, YOLO,
YOLO, YOLO. Oh, das war dumm, ich dachte immer noch, ich bin Mackay. Moment, ist das
jetzt ein Silencer den ich da habe? Ist immer noch so laut. Ok, in dem Game heißt das ja
nicht unbedingt, dass es logisch ist, ne? Man ist so viel. YOLO Style. Sonnens Grenade.
Granate, noch mehr Granate. Bam, bashen. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein,
nein, nein, nein, nein. Da machst du nichts. Skylight Tracer sagt, er geht sich jetzt hinlegen.
Chat, was sagen wir dazu, wenn man sich um diese Uhrzeit hinlegt? Wir haben da schon,
wir haben für dich schon das passende vorbereitet, Skylight Tracer. Wir haben genau das, was jetzt,
schon spät, genau. Schon spät. Betke, schon spät. Boomer müde, Betke. Oh. Ok,
ok. Mein Gott, hier ist so viel los, meine Güte. Was? Na, das hat er gesehen, natürlich,
obvius, obvius, dass er das gesehen hat, gar keine Frage. Vielleicht kriege ich, vielleicht
habe ich Glück und werde, oh, ich werde der Captain Poggers. Es ist der Wahnsinn, Alter,
mein Kopf, man. Aber der Ejax regelt, der Ejax regelt. Alles gut, alles gut. Leute, ich bin
immer zufrieden, wenn man Top 5 Squad ist. Rest ist, Rest ist eigentlich, Rest ist eigentlich
optional. Top 5 Squad ist das, wo es, das wo es ist. Ok, Alter, was ein Stack. Guckt
euch das mal an. Das sind, da können wir keine Stealth-Action machen, da müssen wir Pepega
29 machen. Was anderes geht da nicht. Ich glaube, Pepega 29 ist hier der einzige Weg,
dass wir da durchkommen. Pepega 29, mehr geht nicht. Jawoll, gib ihm, Ejax, mach sie fertig.
Aber für zwei, die du killst, respawn acht neue. Vielleicht können wir, vielleicht haben
wir Glück, vielleicht haben wir Glück. Warte mal, wir probieren mal was. Ich sehe nichts.
Oh, hier ist aus. Warum ist hier aus? Hier ist überhaupt nicht als aus markiert auf der
Map. Keck wait. Oh fuck, hier ist so offen, man. Ich dachte, ich habe jetzt den richtig
krassen Hyper-Flank gemacht, aber ich bin noch nicht mal halb rum. Shit. Gut. Pepega
29, Leute, ich sage es euch. Das ist da way. Ich sehe den Gegner nicht mal, auf den ich
gerade schieße, aber ich kriege mal Hitmarker. Ich sehe die Gegner nicht. So muss man schießen,
ich muss mich mal anstrengen. Ich muss mich mal anstrengen jetzt mit der Waffe. Du musst
eigentlich burst schießen. Ich bin nur zu faul zum burst schießen. Oh, Pepega 29 ist
leer. Was machen wir da jetzt? Ich würde sagen, wir reloaden einfach mit dem anderen Magazin.
Ich schieße einfach mal in die Richtung. Oh, nächsten Motion Sensor rein. Bäm. Am besten
ist, man bleibt am Leben. Ich glaube, die Rätsel wiederbeleben sich da gerade. Das ist
aber nicht erlaubt. Das ist ziemlich illegal, finde ich. Das sollte den definitiv nicht
erlaubt sein, sich wiederzubeleben. Ein Pence, man. Kannst du dich heilen, please, mit deiner
Putz. So und jetzt Anti-Dings-Granaten. Okay. Seriously? Ich habe das irgendwo hingeworfen
und es fliegt jetzt auf den Heli. Man kann es ja auch übertreiben. Und ich glaube, mit
den MP-Granaten kann man Fahrzeuge disablen. Streamst du morgen wieder? Soll ich? Kann
ich machen? Das Rhetorische Frage. Ich gehe mal schon davon aus, dass jemand sagt, ja,
Blitz. Hast du Standard? Nein, das war ganz, das war ganz schlecht. Nein, das ist zu groß.
Please. Wow, hui hui hui. Monka. Ein richtiger Monka-S-Moment. Eax regelt mit dem Little Bird.
Eax macht das. Was ist denn hier los? Was ist hier? Es ist immer der, den du nicht siehst,
der dich killt. Ich sehe, ich sehe den Dude noch nicht mehr. Oh. Okay, nice. PP-Gan 29.
Okay, hier rennt einer durchs Aus. Hier kann eigentlich nichts mehr sein. Gehen wir mal
rüber. Ich höre noch was, aber ich gehe jetzt nicht. Vielleicht kann ich hier starten.
Warte mal, vielleicht kann ich von hier starten. Nein, das geht, das geht Leute, das geht von
hier. Fuck. Warum kann ich nicht lauschen von hier? Was ist das? Warum kann ich den Wingsuit
nicht aufmachen? Das ist total Mist. Okay, weggesniped. Der Eax macht das, der Eax war
mit dem Little Bird alles weg. Es ist, wie soll ich sagen? Alter, Eax, du machst das
jetzt echt fertig. Es ist halt sehr wenig intuitiv. Nice, das überlebe ich immer auch
immer. So, das ist der Way, wie man überlebt mit so einem Wingsuit. Jetzt habt ihr gesehen,
falls ihr mal in die Situation kommt, dass ihr mit einem Wingsuit irgendwie runter müsst,
dann geht das so. Hier lernt man was fürs Leben. Hier lernt man wirklich was fürs Leben.
Immer der, den du nicht siehst. Immer schön im Kopf landen. Ja, so sieht es aus. Ah,
Beste Squad, Beste Squad. Executioner. Executioner Squad. So wirklich, so wirklich unten. Ach,
da sind sie. Nein. Nein. Ich muss euch Pepega 29. Der hat die Granate nicht geswitcht.
Ich dachte, ich hatte die Waffe ab, die Waffe in der Hand. Ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher,
dass ich eins gedrückt habe. Aber wir schaffen das, glaube ich, fast zu Defenden. So, hier,
nochmal. Ich darf nicht aussteigen. Was ist hier los? Wie geht's? Schon spät. Ja, geht
los. So, Peter May und das Game ist immer noch nicht ready und ist auch nicht ansatzweise
den Kaufpreis wert. Ach ja, es war die Frage, ob ich mir das gekauft habe. Nee, ich hatte
die Ehre und habe einen Code bekommen, was auch ganz gut war. Immer der, oh, da ist ja
alles davor. Das sind ja 20 Stück. Okay, das war richtig Pepega, da ich überhaupt reingeflogen
bin. Es ist nichts Balanced, sagt Skorki. Ja, das stimmt. Es ist wenig, wenig Balanced.
Das eigentliche Problem ist aber gar nicht so sehr die Balance. Das eigentliche Problem
ist, dass das Spiel unfertig ist. Also nicht mit Bugs mal so sehr, sondern vom Design her
unfertig. Ich habe den One-Hit-Sniper. Vielleicht werde ich... Ach, der steht da. Der steht
einfach da. Den habe ich überhaupt nicht gesehen, den Kerl. Wo? Hier, hier irgendwie,
oder? Wo ist der Dude? Oder wurde es einfach nur in der Killcam jetzt falsch angezeigt,
dass der näher dran ist, als er letztendlich ist? Oder ist das schon wieder tot oder? Man
weiß es nicht. Jawoll, Punkte schießen. Wie habe ich das vermisst? Vielleicht, wenn wir
noch ein paar... Moment, wir machen das jetzt so. Wir werfen da einen Motion Sensor rein
und wenn der Motion Sensor was spottet, schießen wir durch den Rauch mit der Minigun. Die ist
aber schon anderweitig besetzt. Ja, alles klar. P.P. 29. Ich bin froh, Team, dass ihr so abgeht,
weil ich gehe diese Runde definitiv nicht ab. Aber ich weiß auch nicht, was ich anders
machen soll, gerade wenn ich ehrlich bin. Du kommst halt über diese flachen Sachen
nur sehr, sehr schwer rüber. Jetzt fallen ja auch die ganzen 30 Millionen Hovercrafts
rum. Das ist ein Gegner. Wo gehen wir denn? Was machen wir denn jetzt? 50 Millionen Hovercrafts?
Schneibers? Guck mal, die aimen mich schon ab. Die aimen mich alle schon ab. Okay, ich
weiß, was wir jetzt brauchen, Leute. Wir brauchen einen Drop. Ich bekomme keinen Drop. Ich bin
zu schlecht für einen Drop. Ich bekomme keinen Drop. Ja, ja, ja. Was? Yeah, ein Kill. Noch
nicht mal ein Kill. Das ist bugged. Okay, jetzt aber. Jetzt aber. Alpha One. Auf geht's.
Gib ihm. Volle Pulle. Yolo Alpha One. Rorschensensor. Alpha One. Alpha One. Warum heilst du dich
nicht mit dem Midi-Pen, wenn ich den drücke? Also gerade ist wirklich schlimm. So viele
neue im Channel wegen Battlefield. Ja, nice. Aber gerade ist wirklich schlimm. Ich kann
nicht, was ich machen soll jetzt. Ich meine, der Spawnpunkt bringt es eigentlich nicht.
Vielleicht habe ich Glück und kann von hier oben irgendwie reinfliegen oder so. Man irgendwas
muss ich ja machen. Nein, natürlich nicht. Das geht natürlich nicht. Please, Battlefield,
sei doch ein bisschen konsistent von wo man starten kann mit diesen Wingsuiten, von wo
nicht. Okay, von hier anscheinend nicht. Du schaust kein YouTube mehr. Vielleicht von
hier. Vielleicht von hier. Von hier, von hier. Nicht, das ist zu flach. Okay, Motion Sensor
rein. Leute, das ist Teamplay da oben. Repair Tools dabei. Habt ihr das gelesen? Er hat
Repair Tools dabei. Das ist mal Einsatz für ein Team, Mann. Richtig nice. Okay, ich Defende
das jetzt hier im Hovercraft. Sobald... Serious, wir hätten eingenebelt. Sobald da jetzt irgendwie
einer nur seinen Kopf rausstreckt. Sobald da einer seinen Kopf rausstreckt, wird's gebashed.
Okay, das wird so nix. Moment, nein, das war kein Gegner. Alter, hör auf, hör auf,
hör auf dich zu heilen. Man kann das nicht abbrechen. Man kann das nicht abbrechen mit
dem Heilen. Gülle, Gülle, Gülle. Ich glaube, ich mach mal kurz die Mario-Musik im Hintergrund
aus. Die ist etwas leicht irritierend. E-Hacks hat 59 Kills, Richtsport, Captain Poggers macht
mit. Executioner Squad hier, Mann. Wie, haben die das wieder eingenommen jetzt? Nee, oder?
Wo geh ich rein? Wo geh ich rein? Da, da. Wo pushen die mehr? Wo pushen die mehr? Also
mein Squad ist hier, dann geh ich hier rein. Jetzt haben wir's. Okay, wir haben's geschafft.
Good Job, sagt er. Das geht übrigens, warum ist die Minimap jetzt verdeckt? Wie war das
Video heute auf, ziemlich negativ zu wirken? Naja, ich hab einfach daran gedacht, dass
ich fett Kohle für bekomme, dann war das nicht mehr so wild. Achso, wir dürfen noch
nicht. Wir dürfen noch nicht. Das war ziemlich blöd hier lang zu fliegen. Wir dürfen ja
noch gar nicht. Ah ja, Leute, wenn ich vielleicht nächstes Jahr, ich darf immer noch nicht.
Nice. Wenn ich nächstes Jahr noch ein bisschen weniger arbeite, vielleicht hab ich Glück.
Vielleicht hab ich Glück. Ah nee, ist schon down, okay. Übrigens, by the way, das ist
gar nicht mal wirklich geplant, mit dem noch weniger arbeiten. Nice. Immerhin hast du den
Grafik-Bug erwähnt. Ich muss tappen. Ich bin so faul, Leute. Ich bin so faul. Es ist
der Wahnsinn. Hätte ich den getappt, wäre der dreimal gestorben. Aber nein, lieber,
ppega29 machen. So, jetzt hier. Oh, dieses Hochhaus, das ist die schwerste Base auf der
ganzen Map, finde ich. Weil egal, was du machst, du kriegst eigentlich immer auf den Sack.
Ich geh mal mit dem Captain Poggers hier jetzt zusammen hoch. Aber da oben, wir werden jetzt
direkt erwartet schon, falls ich überhaupt hochkomme. Falls ich überhaupt schaff, hoch
zu kommen. Man kann mit dem Hovercraft die Wand hochfahren, das funktioniert. Ja, man
kann mit dem Hovercraft da hochfahren. Ich sag doch, wir werden schon von 20 Gegnern
erwartet. Und von was wurden wir gekillt? Ppega29. Hovercraft, jawoll. Ich dachte, unser
Hovercraft ist schon auf dem Dach. Ach, Eax, willst du hochfahren? Dann gucken wir uns
das jetzt mal an. Da muss man ja ein ganz spezieller Owner sein, dass das funktioniert.
Ich hab's auch noch nicht genau gecheckt, wie das funktioniert. Aber es geht, man kann
mit dem Hovercraft jetzt. Das macht meine Boomerhand nicht mit, dass ich die treffe
so. Oh, Hacker-Mant. Okay. Hacker-Mant. Okay, wir probieren's nochmal. Achtung. Da oben.
Da guckt schon... Ah, nee, das ist nur eine LED. Achtung, Achtung. She baited, she baited.
Kann ich da... Kann ich... Kann ich... Ah, ich muss turnen. Da unten ist was. Da unten
ist was. Hier ist noch mehr. Richtig krasser She baited war das. Habt ihr's gesehen? Massive
She baited. Einfach, er ist einfach down. Okay, nochmal She baited, nochmal She baited,
nochmal She baited. Der ist er schon. Sieh den, sieh den. She baited, she baited. Alter,
das Wingsuit-Ding ist broken, das macht er nicht mit. Wir She baiten jetzt einfach paar
Mine, die machen wir mit der Band jetzt. Ja. Er acreditet schon. Du schmerz overnight.
hochfahren kann was hat mich gekillt eine sentry gun hat mich gekillt sonst
war hier gar nichts wir haben sogar chancen das einzunehmen von hinten das
sentry gun oder sentry gun fuck sag na hier wäre ich bestimmt nicht wieder
belebt oben die explosive kills ja wahrscheinlich wirft da aus dem heli
wirft da aus dem heli ist nicht ein nicer respawn beacon habt ihr auch gesehen das
angeblich hier was war übrigens was auch schlimm ist dass das dieses ding hier
das ist alles überlagert dieser marker
game common common game
danke er ist pock oder kommt fast von hinten shit von hinten von hinten kommt
da was hoch achso nee no red spark ach nee captain peng macht der uns alle weg
not enough space alter was ist denn an b1 da gerade los
ach nee b1 ist ja das hochhaus richtig richtig hängen geblieben also jetzt mal
ernsthaft was genau haben die sich dabei gedacht dass man auf dieses hochhaus nur
über die treppen oder über dieses oder diese diese fahrstuhl ziplines kann was
ist was ist der sinn davon hat das jemand hat diese krasse design logik
jemand verstanden ich noch nicht so ganz
du bist auch partner meister es müsste ich verstehen weil ich weil ich partner
bin oder guckt es euch an guckt es euch an
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher von wo ehrlich gesagt die hier unten schon hier
unten stellt was guckt euch das man hier oder nee oder doch oben mein gott was
ein klitsch fest
ok ich gehe jetzt auch hier hoch jolo ist es da ist es da nicht ist es dahinten
oder ist reloaden das reloaden war glaube ich keine allzu clevere idee
du kannst hier nichts kühlen es ist nicht möglich das ist es ist zu viel es ist
zu viel ich mein mehr als hoch drei leute kühlen in 40 gegnern ist kannst
du doch kannst du doch nicht machen use zipline in the middle ja das wird es
auch nicht ändern
dann use wir mal die zipline in the middle also ich zeige ich zeige euch mal
diese also der mein die hier aber es gibt noch eine andere zipline die bringt
er aber nicht hoch wir haben noch die zipline hier im fahrstuhl aber die
bringt nicht nur in ersten stock und das bringt nichts hier ist ja auch gar
nichts los im endeffekt so man kann irgendwie von hier dann auch weiter hoch
aber da bin ich zu bin ich zu pp gar da
was genau ist jetzt gestorben ich habe so nicht gecheckt irgendwo hier
ging es noch weiter rauf ach da
oh oh das alter dieses dieses map design hier ist einfach komplett die genialität
die ist einfach da bin ich einfach zu zu zu small schmoll im hirn dass ich das
verstehen könnte wie man sich gedacht hat dieser punkt auf dem hochhaus wäre
eine gute idee
man hat null den man hat überhaupt kein man hat nichts hier in diesem an diesem
hochhaus ist vielleicht von der seite gepascht
perfekt ich renne jetzt einfach im kreis weil er trifft mich nix sehr gut ja
perfekt nice jebaited wo ist denn hier was da was ppega so krass ppega haben
habe ich die habt ihr das gesehen schon spät kann ich dazu nur sagen schon
spät jetzt emt sie mich ab jetzt emt sie mich ab weil sie ist ja nicht dumm
es hat aber auch wieder nicht gehitzt hat auch wieder durchgeschossen teilweise
war war blöd ich habe es ja noch gesagt jetzt emt sie mich ab aber nein ich
musste ja noch mal hin stay away
okay was können wir realistisch betrachtet machen um da oben rein zu kommen
außer mit hovercrafts an der wand hochklitschen und selbst das bringt es
nicht sonderlich
eigentlich nix oder wenn ich das richtig sehe eigentlich eigentlich nix
eigentlich machst du hier nix pp 29 ppega 29 akimbo
aber das ist eine gute idee motion sensor hochschmeißen guck mal
es ist spät schon spät schon spät enemy sportet enemy sportet enemy sportet
enemy sportet aber es hat auch nichts gebracht wenn ich den gekillt hätte
gab es nicht einen day one patch doch es gab einen day one patch aber der hat
so gut wie nix gepatcht es ist fast nicht einnehmbar hier ich
habe es einmal gesehen und ich habe die map jetzt zwar nicht wahnsinnig oft aber
schon ein paar mal gespielt auch hier breakthrough ja ja ich verstehe ich aber
du hast halt du hast halt keine chance im endeffekt kommen ach miss ich bin ja
gar nicht was anders wohl
wer hat sich gedacht das ist eine gute idee
ein bord und easy einnehmen ja ein bord sollten wir machen ein bord ist eine gute
idee wusste ich dass du da bist das hat man
wofür ist diese tür warum kann man die zu machen
das ist glaube ich dass das use ist der map detail an der zeiten glaubst du die
der wusste dass das spiel ja definitiv und ich glaube auch nicht dass sie
wirklich wollten dass monka ich glaube auch nicht dass sie wirklich wollten dass
das spiel in diesem zustand released wird kann ich mir nicht vorstellen
glaube ich einfach nicht immer von der seite man ich glaube nicht dass die
wollten dass das spiel released wird in diesem in diesem zustand nehmen
kommen wir kommen ist der er raus sind wir sind viel platz anstatt platz eins
platz sechs das ist für den modus noch gekommen ja das ist das ist quasi der
rush ersatz also die die die die entwickler wussten das und die
entwickler glaube ich auch nicht dass die dass die das wollten in in diesem
zustand zu releasen
als sie jetzt springen wir vom dach rein was ja auch nichts bringt also wie
gesagt diese hochhaus potts die kammer nur einnehmen
entweder wenn 64 man die richtig gut sind gegen 64 kaknubs spielen
achtung wir machen jetzt mal was die stehende habt ihr es gesehen die
stehende mit dem auto drinnen die stehende mit dem auto drin ja was soll ich
machen es ist nicht möglich ich kann es nichts machen
es ist einfach nur hängen geblieben
ich bin ja miss ich bin ja der falsche ich bin ja nicht der mit den granaten
shit aber die sitzt da oben mit du machst nichts das ist wirklich also das
design ist echt gülle habe ich mich übrigens auch in meinem video was
morgen kommt drüber ausgelassen dass die breakthrough maps einfach zu helfen
nicht spielbar sind wie man hier sieht immer ein was was was willst du machen
es ist ja noch nicht mal dass es daran liegt dass sie uns outplayen die stehen
einfach und 30 leute eben jeweils einen einen entry point ab was willst du was
willst du was willst du tun ja
ach ja und die weppen highlights sind auch dumm dass man dann ja dann die
gegner nicht mehr sieht
ja alles klar sehr fär
geil wie der hund gerade explodiert ist
ich gehe da gar nicht hoch das lohnt sich nicht schon spät um die ecke
guck mal man kann mit der waffe jetzt auch richtig gut um die ecke schießen
wusste das schon
gibt es eigentlich nur eins als nein nein es gibt es gibt auch warte mal ich
kann es jetzt zeigen es gibt auch wenn meine waffe mir dazu es gibt auch
visiere und sowas elfi 3 netcode ist noch drin aber ich mag die visiere ich spiele
am liebsten ein und seit ich komme damit irgendwie am besten klar
das ding ist mega mega pepo fett guckt euch mal was für einen fetten was für
einen fetten sirenzeit ich mache die runde noch fertig alle runde ist eh
durch das klar ich habe den hochfunds dann hat
immer vor gg eats wp so meine güte das war anstrengend
irisch wie groß ist das der day one patch ja der day one patch wird
wahrscheinlich gerüchte zu folgen irgendwie 60 g oder so
was echt mehr ja ja was was mehr als das game ist
ja es kommt noch was das können wir uns moment leute das gucken wir uns schnell
noch an bevor betke angesagt ist bennett field patch plan oder sowas weiß ich
mal was was soll ich zeitplan für notwendige patches laut es ist nicht offiziell es ist
es ist liegt alle akzeptieren akzeptieren und schließen das ist ja super also danke
pc games dass ihr mir sagt was ich alles akzeptiere aber ich akzeptiere alles kein
problem also sie haben geleakt und zwar genau dass es day 10 patch gibt und day
25 patch dass sie nahem machen aber nicht sinn so und die haben die nicht mal die
die den tag hinschreiben können also ich bilde mir an am 30. kommt was
kommt noch ein patch das ist der nächste das ist glaube ich der day das ist dann
der day also 19 ist wahrscheinlich der day 10 der day 10 patch oder sowas also
der hier oben steht es ja zehn tage nach lies und das andere am 7 september ja
das ist das was geleakt wurde der day one patch der gestern gekommen ist der
macht nichts der reduziert ein bisschen das rubber bending aber ansonsten im
grossen und ganzen macht er macht er einfach gar nichts
also der hat nichts geändert weder hovercraft op noch irgendwie map balance
noch überhaupt was von was in dem game einfach geändert einfach gar nichts
es hat bei genau es hat bei manchen leuten bisschen dazu geführt dass es
wohl weniger leckt das habe ich auch schon gelesen aber insgesamt an den
eigentlichen problemen des spiels hat er gar nichts gemacht
die dumme vermutung habe ich auch dass sie die maps nicht mehr großartig
anfassen werden sie müssen die maps anfassen sie
haben orbital auch schon angefasst also orbital hat jetzt drei mehr kisten auf
dem flugplatz aber die anderen maps müssen sich anpassen ich denke auch dass
sie sie über kurz oder lang machen werden wenn ihnen das management nicht
instant den stecker zieht weil das game sieht ich meine ich habe es euch ja
vorhin gezeigt mit meta kritik das sieht weder so ist es sogar noch
untergegangen jetzt aber sogar 2,3
also weder weder auf meta kritik noch auf steam sieht das wahnsinnig gut aus ich
mein man kann eigentlich nur hoffen auf der einen seite dass das spiel sich gut
verkauft dass es weiter supporten werden irgendwie die leute was für ihr geld
irgendwann mal bekommen aber auf der anderen seite würde ich ihnen eigentlich
auch wünschen dass es ein kolossaler reinfall wird obwohl das vielleicht das
ende für battlefield bedeuten würde wobei das glaube ich nicht wirklich also
in den battlefield wird es kommen die maps sind detailer und lieblos ja das
wirkt alles äußerst lieblos und steril und meine vermutung ist ja also
meine vermutung also ich finde was dieses game am besten beschreibt ist das ist
wenn man sagt hey das wurde einfach also das ist doppelt unfertig das game das
ist nicht nur unfertig programmiert das ist auch in das ist auch quasi die die
konzeption und design phase gar nicht abgeschlossen
das wurde einfach mitten in der entwicklung entschlossen
hey leute in einem halben jahr muss das game rauskommen dazu kommt auch noch dass
das game ja ursprünglich mal als battle royale angefangen hat und oder was
heißt das bettel ja vielleicht vielleicht war auch hazard zone ursprünglich da
und sie haben festgestellt ok hazard zone alleine trägt nicht da müssen wir
noch was anderes machen ein lass mal wieder ein klassisches battlefield machen
aber wo ich ihnen wirklich böse drum bin und ich spiele jetzt gar nicht auf die
ganzen bugs und sonst was an das ist ein eigenes thema aber wo ich ihnen
wirklich böse drum bin ist diese irreführende werbung
also das game wurde ja ich weiß ich weiß nicht ob man eine irreführend
sagen kann aber das game so wie das dargestellt wurde dachte man einfach
das ist quasi ein spiel im geiste von battlefield 3 und auch das hier so was
guckt euch guckt euch guckt euch sowas hier an
das ist jetzt halt portal aber guckt es so was an es ist alles was man sieht es
ist einfach nur so halbherzig drin und das also diese werbung und dass sie
halt gnadenlos die auf die fans diese werbung zugeschnitten haben die schon
jahrelang auf ein neues modernes battlefield warten also quasi ihre
treuesten der treuesten fans die immer noch am start sind dass sie die quasi
damit ausgenommen haben das nehme ich ihnen ja wieder ein bisschen übel und
das ist auch der punkt wo ich mir denke hey eventuell ich glaube zwar nicht
könnte das aber wirklich wenn das ein richtig großer flop wird das
vorübergehende ende für battlefield bedeuten das komplette ende garantiert
nicht rebootet wird immer irgendwann was
ja und da bin ich ihnen wirklich ein bisschen böse drum und ich denke die
steam bewertungen sprechen für sehr für sich selbst und die meta kritik
dinger sprechen auch für sich selbst ich muss noch ein sponsored video machen
über hazard zone da werde ich am wochenende mit einem squad ein bisschen
spielen und irgendwas zu machen ich habe ich habe gesagt ich habe zugesagt ich
mache drei ich mache drei sponsored video das erste war das über portal das
nächste war das heute und dann muss ich noch eins über hazard zone machen
metaschore 74 ja lass uns doch mal reingucken wir hatten das so gut bewertet
egm 100 prozent seriously 100 prozent was ist das welches ich muss mir dieses
review angucken welche seite gibt diesem spiel 100 prozent ist das sponsor ist
es sponsored review sponsored review battlefield review ok also ok ok das muss
wir jetzt muss man kennt diese seite jemand egm habe ich noch nie habe ich noch nie gehört vom 11 november das ist ja gut
donnerstag ok das ist durfte sogar einst vor vor vor early x also battlefields
always bin wir lesen das hat sich viel plus den anfangen lesen difficult
difficult franchise pinda und his children modern is it competitive for
cash is a technical team-based experience was im early good place to
fregort answer is yes alles klar
die haben noch nicht mal footage von ihren sachen drin das ist ein review was
geschrieben wurde von jemanden das gelblich geschrieben gespielt hat stock
footage komplett stock footage footage also wie nennt man das nicht stock
footage press material komplett nicht ein einziges eigenen screenshot nicht ein
einziges eigenes gameplay das ist wahrscheinlich wisst ihr was das ist
wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal sponsored die sind wahrscheinlich so verzweifelt
dass ihr nichts anderes mehr einfällt
das ist ernst gemeint das ist ernst gemeint vielleicht ist es auch sponsored
das ist alles alles presser material
early days but promising future außer dass das spiel in der zukunft
spielt sehe ich da nicht so eine krasse promising future für das ja 100 prozent
alles klar alles klar hat auch keine kommentare was ein trash also mal ganz im
ernst so was haben wir hier sonst auf welche twin findet habe ich auch noch
nie gehört noisy pixel kenne ich auch nicht
kock connected habe ich auch noch nie gehört ok in irgendwelche proger
seiten 90 90 90 85 85 was hatten hat die game star schon eine finale also ich muss
sagen man kann man kann über die game style viel herziehen aber ich muss sagen
ich finde die game size immer noch auch wenn er ziemlich viel unnötiges
geklickbete mittlerweile ist die muss er irgendwie geld verdienen ok immer noch
das beste spieler magazin in der richtung was wir haben
haben die schon in haben die schon ein test
was für ein schlachtfeld ok das ist bestimmt das ist bestimmt game star plus
das ist bestimmt plus ich wusste es 71 ok damit kann ich leben
wisst ihr ich hätte nämlich gesagt ich hätte gesagt höchsten 70 prozent aufs
kriegen aber das ist das ist in ordnung also die
game star begründet die sachen ja in der regel meistens relativ sinnvoll und wenn
man mal wirklich sagen also diese die versuchen das ja immer so ok ich muss
alles an für mich ist ist ist wie ich ein spiel finde hauptsächlich eine eine
keine also keine einschätzung die ich jetzt anhand einer checkliste abhaken
kann also es gibt jetzt für mich bei einer
spielebewertung oder wie ich ein spiel empfinde kann ich nicht sagen grafik
checken animationen checken connection checken 1 2 3 und dann mache ich
checkliste dran am ende kommt 70 prozent aus das funktioniert für spiele bei mir
nicht die game star versucht das ein bisschen
wobei die auch andere redakteure haben und nachdem das eine subjektive sache ist
will ich mal gegen die 70 prozent gar nicht sagen zumal man auch sagen muss
dass für game star verhältnisse 71 prozent eigentlich schon ziemlicher
trash ist also alles was bei der game star nicht
mindestens 80 prozent plus hat lohnt sich in der regel eigentlich nicht zu
spielen
so also was sagen sie denn hier wenn ihr der sandbox chaos von
battlefield liebt es hat eindeutig zu viel chaos diesmal und zu
undurchdacht ist ihr mit bekannten im squad spielen möchtet das geht ja auch
nur zum teil du kannst zwar deine leute in weit aber squad wechseln und leute
auf dem server wiederfinden und vielleicht sogar neue bekannte machen im
spiel geht nicht mit immensen spielzahlen volt ich glaube
niemand sagt ich hätte gern eine moderne military action mit immensen
spielzahlen ich glaube die leute sagen ich hätte ein gutes spiel es ist es ist
also wissen die leute sagen es wäre es ist cool dass die 128 spieler gut
umgesetzt hat dann will ich es haben aber nicht also 128 spieler allein ist jetzt
ja weder noch ein guter noch ein schlechter punkt es ist die frage wie
ist 128 spieler eben umgesetzt
ja ja ein shooter mit reibungsloser balance erwartet naja das gab es in
bettel viel tatsächlich so gut wie noch nie das stimmt nimmt auch empfindlich
auf bugs glitches und performance problem also es ist ja nicht nur das das ist
einfach komplett undurchdacht guckt euch breakthrough die maps an
na gut was sagen was sagen die kommentare
ok wahrscheinlich wir die üblichen fanboy battles aber ich ich kann es nur
noch mal sagen also ich verstehe nicht warum in der heutigen zeit kritik oftmals
gleich hassen oder hate aufgefasst wird das einzige was das bringt ist wenn man
quasi nicht mehr kritisiert und wenn man alles schön redet das streichelt zwar
so ein bisschen so die fanboy seele oder vielleicht kann man sich dann schön
reden naja ich muss mir nicht eingestehen 120 euro in sand gesetzt zu
haben aber wozu das führt ist immer schlechtere
spiele umso sehr man das schön redet umso
sehr man das durchgehen lässt umso schlechter werden die spiele in zukunft
rauskommen kam ich denke man kann es nachvollziehen
wie ich das meine oder und das darf es einfach nicht sein
es ist immer ansichtssache ich ich wie gesagt ich gönne das auch jedem wenn er
wenn er das spiel abfeiern und an den spaß seines lebens drin hat aber
trotzdem finde ich sollte man nicht auf beiden augen blind sein
vielleicht weil man noch krassere bettel vor viel fanboy ist wie ich uns nicht
einsehen will oder weil man wirklich sagt es ist das beste bettel vieler
sein aber zumindest sollte man nicht auf
einem auge blind sein dass es für eine riesen zahlen der leute eben
performance technisch überhaupt nicht läuft und auch nicht dass das spiel
massive bugs und und und unfertigkeits probleme hat wenn es einem gefällt
würde ich sagen kriegen wir sich nicht mehr das gameplay sollte man nicht
ignorieren und wir wollen doch alle nicht dass
solche spiele die regel werden oder das will auch eigentlich keiner und umso
mehr wird das durchgehen lassen und kaufen und quasi schön reden umso
größer ist die wahrscheinlichkeit dass das immer mehr die regel wird
das war im prinzip schon immer so ja aber das bettel viel schon immer
verbackt released wurde ist für mich kein argument was ich gelten lasse weil
erstens nur weil was schon immer verpackt released wurde was ja so gar
nicht bei bettel viel unbedingt immer stimmt aber selbst wenn das stimmen
würde ist das kein argument für zu sagen hey dann muss das diesmal jetzt
auch so sein man könnte ja auch aus problemen lernen das wäre auch eine
möglichkeit ja und jetzt habe ich vergessen wo ich
gerade gewesen bin lull schon spät boomer boomer gehirn hab gesagt dass
ich hab gesagt es ist kein argument dass das spiel verbackt rauskommt
keine ahnung ich weiß es nicht was ich sagen wollte
guckt euch mein video morgen an da ist das alles drin
ja ach ja und jetzt wird wieder eingefallen was meinst du das ernst ich
meine jedem seine meinung ja wenn du das empfinde es ist ok aber ernsthaft wir
reden jetzt mal vom bettel viel 4 zu release zu bettel viel 2042 zu release
meine ansicht ist bettel viel 2042 um einiges unfertiger sogar noch als
bettel viel 4 und der unterschied zwischen bettel viel 4 und bettel viel
2042 ist dass ich persönlich in bettel viel 4
einen spielenswerten oder ein ich habe gestern so einen goldenen spielenswerten
kern gesehen habe und man sagen könnte ja das spiel ist poggers aber da fehlt
noch einiges bei bettel viel 2042 habe ich eher den eindruck da fehlt noch
einiges und das spiel ist auch nicht poggers das spiel ist nämlich nicht zu
ende gedacht weil man es einfach auf den markt geschmissen hat das ist wie
gesagt doppelt unfertig und das habe ich bei bettel viel 4 nicht gesehen aber ich
sehe es bei bettel viel 2042 und ich sehe auch nicht wie sie das ändern
wollen mit dieser map und spieleranzahl philosophie
natürlich könnten die sagen hey und das ist das was was ich denke was
sagen wir mal kurzfristig zumindest vielen alten bettel viel spieler auch
spaß Spaß machen würde ist wenn man sich gute zonen auf den maps raussucht
ich meine die maps sind groß genug wir könnten eigentlich aus jeder map
uns 2 bis 3 ja manche maps ist es komplett verloren da lässt einfach weg
man könnte sich aus jeder map 2 bis 3 gute bettel viel zonen raussuchen und
dort zumindest so was in der richtung mal wie domination oder so anbieten 32
versus 32 oder 24 versus 24 das lässt sich glaube ich kurzfristig relativ gut
umsetzt domination dürfte easy sein für die und die maps sind ja schon da dann
könnte man zumindest die maps recyceln für spieler die eben kein spaß an 128
clusterfuck haben wer spaß an 128 clusterfuck hat ist ja vollkommen in
ordnung da sage ich ja gar nichts dagegen aber für die die das nicht haben
und das scheint ein nicht unerheblicher teil zu sein wenn man sich die
bewertung anguckt und wenn man sich reddit post und das gerannte über das
spiel anguckt ich persönlich bin damit auch nicht so happy und man könnte
relativ einfach aus diesen maps 20 20 kleinere machen und ich meine nicht dass
man die wirklich neu mappen sollte sondern einfach nur ein rotes marker wo
wo wo sie verlassen das kampfgebiet drinne ist
so sehe ich das das könnte man relativ relativ easy machen
ob sie es machen werden mal gucken ich glaube aber dass es für das überleben
das spiels wichtig ist weil aktuell scheint es mir so als rennen die leute
quasi schon ein paar tage nach release weg
was glaubst du ist der intern abgegangen also ich glaube schon dass die
entwickler nicht dieses spiel in diesem zustand releasing wollten
die super krassen stonks manager haben gesagt leute wir brauchen irgendwas für
weihnachten oder sie haben gesagt hey wir modeln unser battle royale in
battlefield um aber es passt von unseren plänen nur für 2021 wer weiß was die
geplant hat für zweites wissen wir ja gar nicht und dann hat man gesagt hey wir
nehmen jetzt das obwohl es erst halbfertig durchdacht halbfertig
entwickelt ist wir polieren es ist es fällt mir schwer ich dieses wort zu
benutzen bei battlefield 2042 aber wir versuchen es so weit wie möglich zu
polieren was wir jetzt haben bis ende des jahres und dann haben wir das raus
und gucken ob es irgendwie noch ein bisschen weiter halbwegs brauchbar
patchen können dass das spiel sagen wir mal 1 2 jahre vielleicht überlebt also
ich kann mir bei dem aktuellen zustand beim besten will nicht vorstellen dass
battlefield 2042 battlefield 2042 das nächste rainbow six sie wird was ja auch
nicht gut gestartet ist und aber immer noch jetzt quasi von rainbow six sie war
ja auch hier war ja auch diese geschichte
beste beste craft action war ja auch diese geschichte hier quasi okay
mittlerweile ist es ein bisschen ein bisschen flach aber das glaube ich nicht
dass das bei battlefield 2042 passieren wird
wir sollten das eigentlich von dice erwarten dass die ein spielbares spiel
raushauen also wir sollten eigentlich erwarten dass sie ein durchdachtes spiel
raushauen was es nicht ist und wir sollten erwarten dass sie ein spielbares
spiel raushauen und ja man kann sagen man kann ins game und man kann spielen
wenn man wenn man dann kann aber wir hatten doch gestern und heute oder vor
gestern war gestritten haben kaum eine runde ohne irgendwelchen abgetreten
übertriebenen bugs also das das kann man schon von da ist erwarten und wie
gesagt wenn man aufhört so was zu zu fordern oder wenn man das einfach so
hinnimmt wird es dazu führen dass es immer mehr akzeptiert wird dass
unfertige schlechte spiele rauskommen oder es will ja auch keiner
ja ja auch auch das mit den häusern also wisst ihr was diesem spiel gefehlt hat
dieses spiel hat gefällt erstens natürlich normale entwicklungszyklus
und dauer und dem haben vor allem die internen iterationen gefällt dass man
ausprobiert man hat ja nichts dagegen es ist ja kein problem 128 spieler aus
zu probieren und das zu testen aber dann hätte man vielleicht gesagt hey das
macht so wie es jetzt ist kein spaß wir ändern mal was wir probieren das neu
aus wir ändern mal was wir probieren das neu aus vielleicht kommt man zu dem
schluss 128 spieler funktioniert überhaupt nicht vielleicht hätte man
das spiel anders designen müssen das 128 spieler richtig funktionieren aber das
hat man nicht gemacht man hat einfach gesagt hey das muss jetzt raus
wir nehmen das was wir haben man sieht es doch schon daran wusste
dir dass das spiel eine hintergrundgeschichte hat es gab einen
story trailer und angeblich hatte dieses spiel hintergrundgeschichte dass die
welt quasi am abgrund steht hungersnöte alles im arsch überschwemmungen davon ist
nichts im spiel gelandet okay in dem intro vielleicht ein bisschen es es ist
nichts davon guckt euch die specialist seiten an hier
guckt euch guckt euch die specialist seiten an also da gibt es da gibt es
geschichten konzept konzept bilder alles möglich also man hat sich da schon
gedanken gemacht aber man hat es nie fertig gemacht man hat es nie zu ende
gedacht man hat einfach mittendrin gesagt leute wir nehmen das was wir haben und
wir hauen es raus bis zum ende des jahres
und das merkt man das wirkt steril es wirkt lieblos und es wirkt halt leider
zum größten teil so wie eigentlich wie ein schatten von battlefield also man
man kann sehen dass das eigentlich durchaus hätte ein gutes spiel werden
können aber es ist einfach nicht da
also zu battlefield für rubber banding kann ich nur das hier sagen
battlefield für rubber banding ist das hier das beste beispiel
das ist so geil dieser clip ich könnte mich immer wegschmeißen wie er gegen die
wand klatscht ich kann mir das 100 mal angucken ich muss mich immer drüber
kaputtlachen ist einfach zu geil einfach beschleunigt einfach klatscht gegen die
wand ja das ist auch was das ja das kommt
auch noch auch für mich noch dabei in battlefield 2042 dass das spiel kaum
content hat man muss ja sagen wir reden in battlefield 2042 von zwei spielmodi
und sieben maps und die maps sind auch nur groß und haben ansonsten eigentlich
nicht sonderlich viele details oder hingucker wenn man noch hazard zone
dabei nehmen haben wir noch ein dritten spielmodus ok aber die maps bleiben
gleich das war es das spiel hat ich habe in
irgendeinem review gelesen die größte battlefield packung aller Zeiten nein das
spiel hat fast nichts und wenn jetzt einer mit portal ankommt portal ist nur
wirklich nicht der kern des spiels portal ist quasi ein da war ein netter
ein netter zusatz den man wahrscheinlich meiner vermutung nach zum größten teil
eingebaut hat damit man die 150 billionen entwickler die man hatte
irgendwie parallel sinnvoll beschäftigen konnte was man mit diesen
massen entwicklern gemacht hat ist mir nicht so ganz klar und ja portal ist eine
gute idee bett company 2 und battlefield 3 in portal sind wenig mit ihren
ursprünglichen vorbildern zu vergleichen sie sind einfach auch nicht
gut im vergleich zu bett company 23 und ich kann genauso gut battlefield 3 und
bett company 2 spielen wenn ich das machen will zu meinen auch noch mehr
inhalt da ist und die spielen sich dann eben auch wie bett company 2 und
battlefield 3 bleibt noch eigene spielmodi kreieren das werden die
wenigsten machen und die fäh und die möglichkeit meiner meinem video gesehen
also wer das wer das sehen will wie man wirklich mal ein bisschen was
komplizierteres programmiert scripted in portal der kann sich der kann sich
man der kann sich mein video angucken hier von vor ein paar tagen das ist auch
fast schon das maximale was geht so und deswegen allein ist portal quasi keine
begründung also portal ist kein lückenfüller für also so kein wild card
argument wo man sagen kann hey an allen ecken und enden fehlt aber portal das
funktioniert nicht und ich will jetzt gar nicht anfangen von
fehlendem server browser keinem keinem gescheiten squad wechseln spieler
bevor mondung und sonst was
richtig genau so ist es man hat von anfang an in battlefield 4 erkannt da
steckt ein gutes game drin es ist halt kaputt aber stecken gutes game drin und
das gefühl habe ich bei 2042 einfach nicht ja genau es ist einfach
lieblosigkeit ja steril lieblos also muss man es jetzt doch nicht kaufen doch
wenn du es nicht kaufst kommt patrick söderlund oder wie dieser typ heißt bei
daheim vorbei da musst du aufpassen
wie heißt er denn ich habe vergessen wie reist das sieht aus als ist er
direkt aus vikings der typ von da ist da hätte ich auch bedenken wenn er von
meiner tür steht und sagt du hast du spiel nicht gekauft da würde ich aber
auch ganz schnell kaufen aber ich weiß was du meinst natürlich du meinst ob
es ein pflichtkauf ist oder nicht nein ist es nicht in aktuellem zustand
definitiv nicht ob es es noch mal wird fraglich alles so meine meinung wisst
ihr wie gesagt ich habe überhaupt keine schmerzen mit wenn irgendjemand das
game richtig abfeiern und das bin das beste spiel aller Zeiten ist wirklich
nicht das freut mich sogar dass da leute spaß dran haben ohne scheiß es macht mich
dann allerdings gleichermaßen etwas satt weil es für mich halt im kern gar
nicht mehr so richtig sich anfühlt wie bettel fielt
ich will weder metro zurück haben und vor allem will ich nicht bazaar mit 128
spielern mithaben stelle euch mal vor metro und bazaar mit 128 spielern also
ich habe es mal wenn es gesehen wie es mit mehr spielern ist also wenn ihr
denkt die maps in battlefield 2042 wenn teilweise clusterfuck
stelle ich mal vor metro bazaar mit explosives 128 spieler dann ist ja
vorbei
glaube ich auch man hätte auch die maps nicht so groß machen müssen die hälfte
die hälfte von kaleidoskop kannst du weglassen die hälfte von our class
kannst du weglassen die hälfte von renewal renewal oder wie das hat kannst du
weglassen kannst eigentlich von allem die hälfte
weglassen und dann vielen sechstens spieler und gut ist dann wäre auch was auf
der map drauf aktuell sind die battlefield 2042 maps einfach so wir haben
einen gebietseditor genommen haben drei container und häuser drauf gestellt und
und fertig ist das ganze ist gerade orbital finde ich schreit richtig nach
so einer vom gebiet her nach so einer battle royale map
ja das sind auch die punkte die spaß machen an dem spiel also das hat
wirklich seine momente das game so ist das gar nicht aber die momente von dem
game sind dort wo eigentlich nichts verschlimmbessert wurde die guten
momente sind zum beispiel wenn du manifest oben im haus am start bist oder
in der container area oder halt irgendwo wie wie vorhin in diesem haus close
quarter action richtig cool aber sobald sommer das eigentliche battlefield 2042
da reinkommt fällt auseinander
ja das finde ich auch nicht gut
echt wie ist das auf reddit so die feiern und die finden scheiße oder
umgedreht richtig genauso ist es das sollte das muss man sich auch
vergegenwärtigen also man sollte nicht anfangen mit so nach dem motto alter
können die nicht programmieren oder so selbstverständlich können sie das das
haben sie auch schon bewiesen und so was in so kurzer zeit hinzukriegen ist ja
auch nicht ohne ich meine es ist ein verbackter haufen und unfertige haufen
aber da können die entwickler glaube ich als letztes was für
neuer tweet ok guck mal mal wird da battlefield kommen haben die geschrieben
die haben geschrieben ok vor zwanzig minuten
oh guck mal da leute wir kriegen wir kriegen neugigkeiten wir kriegen
neugigkeiten patch notes oder oder kommende patch notes oder so poggers
also we are pleased to see that really ist aber ok sie sind blieb das ist so
eine frase also sie sind pleased improve smoothness experience on servers pass
24h alles klar next update inside changes
ach nee das kommt jetzt es kommt jetzt erst ok solja revives
ok es wird gefixt dass manchmal die revives nicht durchgehen das ist gut
älter zwar im kern nichts aber das ist schon mal gut die revives sind ja
aktuell also richtig krasser pains champ doch mehr solch als revive so
zusätzlich noch
ah respawn back wird gefixt sehr gut battlefield werbung vor dem stream
lull ich glaube das sind die genau richtig bei mir mit battlefield werbung ok
revive back ist soll gefixt werden das schon mal gut ist ja eines der
essentiellsten backs ok jv interaction was ist das was was was meinen damit
weiß ich gar verstehe ja aber was meint niemand interaction meint die meint
damit dass man mit casper xp boosten kann oder was
casper drohen xp boost oder oder oder wie oder was ist damit gemeint heißt das
ding überhaupt uav von dem sniper mensch weiß ich hab noch nie drauf
geachtet wie das heißt ok missing loadouts data call to fail
das kennen wir data data persistent error ok das betrifft kein alter also
vehicle balancing ok das ist doch gut es ist es geht schneller kaputt
es hat weniger leben und es macht weniger damage das problem was ich mit
solchen nerf sehe ist dass es meistens über das ziel hinaus schlägt also das
ist so blizzard balancing blizzard balancing ist ja etwas ist op es wird in
gründ und boden genervt danach wird es wieder krass op es wird in gründ und
boden genervt also sprich wenn man nicht nur quasi sagt hey das ding soll
eigentlich als so class kennen fungieren oder so also quasi ganz so easy killen
aber macht fest damage und ist hoch ist ist heiligen mobile dann wäre es jetzt
vielleicht sinnvoll gewesen nicht noch zusätzlich zu sagen hey man macht jetzt
die waffen schwächer aber ganz ehrlich ich habe damit kein problem ich fände
es sogar ganz gut wenn ich das hovercraft jetzt erstmal zwei drei woche
nicht mehr sehen muss ich habe schon wieder ich habe schon genug davon
nightbird das ist der heli was ich bei dem was ich bei dem little bird komisch
finde wenn wenn das der neue little bird ist aber wahrscheinlich dass der jetzt
neuerdings raketen hat um fahrzeuge zu zerstören konnte man in battle field 4
ihr wisst ich bin überhaupt kein heli heli stelzer und fahrzeug typ in
battlefield ich habe ein bisschen panzer gefahren aber heli und und flugzeuge war
nie meins konnte man in battle field 4 auch raketen an die little bird machen
weil das finde ich ein bisschen krass ehrlich gesagt dass der dass der quasi
raketen oder so explosiv geschossen ich weiß nicht ob es wirklich raketen sind
hatten so was haben wir als nächstes ok
ist alles das ist der das ist der patch das ist alles und vor allem am ende
next week das ding ist immer noch broken as fuck also da bestätigen sich so
halt so meine vermutung dass das im endeffekt wahrscheinlich wahrscheinlich
relativ schnell in der versenkung verschwinden wird
huge fixes die müssen jetzt also um dieses spiel wirklich rüber zu retten in
was was langfristig gespielt wird die müssen schnell battlefield content
liefern wo die leute geil drauf sind battlefield mit zu spielen
die brauchen guten battlefield content und nicht erst nächstes jahr
nächstes jahr ist ja bald aber trotzdem nicht erst nächstes jahr
ja also ich kann nur sagen guckt euch morgen mein video an zu dem thema wer
mich noch nicht gesagt hat auf youtube gibt es ja die ein oder anderen gehe ich
mal von aus weil es haben bestimmt jetzt mittlerweile schon hier leute den weg
über twitch hergefunden die man youtube channel nicht kennen könnte bei mir auf
youtube reingucken das video von euch müsste von heute
könnt ihr euch auch angucken wenn ihr bock habt ist aber gesponsert das video
von ei mit dementsprechend relativ wenig geflame über das game wenn ihr
battlefield themen mögt wenn ihr vor allem auch ein bisschen über den
tellerrand was it angeht themen mögt könnt ihr bei mir auf youtube vorbei
gucken wird mich freuen und morgen gibt es dann mein battlefield
fazit was wo ich das game leider etwas härter rannehmen muss aber ich glaube ich
habe das alles noch halbwegs sachlich und begründet gemacht
du bist ab seit zehn jahren richtig poggers schön dass du den weg in stream
gefunden hast dazu kann ich bloß sagen
ach ja und für alle wiebs unter uns gut das muss jetzt mal gesagt werden
natürlich wenn ihr noch weiter mein dummes gelaber hören wollt in textform
könnt ihr auch bei mir auf twitch vorbei gucken oder aber wenn ihr mich
supporten wollt könnt ihr mir auch einen prime sub dalassen wenn ihr noch ein
offen habt auf twitch das wird mich natürlich auch freuen
mal gucken wann es morgen weitergeht morgen vormittag muss ich erst mal ein
bisschen zeug rumräumen im haus muss endlich mal wieder ein bisschen wandern
gehen kommt in die ganze woche nicht dazu gekommen morgen bin ich mal 23
stunden weg morgen vormittag hoffentlich ist
halbwegs gutes wetter muss man kurz checken wie sie wir werden das wetter
morgen ok scheiße
effekt ist weddelfeld fest ich wollte sagen perfekt ist weddelfeld wetter
perfekt ist weddelfeld weder
runter scrollen
danke für den subpoint wer hat eben gesagt ganz gar nicht gesehen richtig
ah joghurt xt nice danke für den sub
huge sub
hanau so schlecht ist hanau auch wiederum nicht ach so du meinst wie in der
geschichte in hanau vor vor zwei jahren oder so ja ja sonst kennt ja niemand
hanau außer daher
perfekt ist hello ich werde es mir auf stream angucken ich werde es mir auf
stream hast du bock zu spielen oder was weil ich glaube halo ist echt ein game
wo man wo man davon profitiert man hat aber gute leute mit aber ich würde es
mir ich würde es mir angucken also ich weiß gar nicht vielleicht heißt
nur zufällig so wie mein wie mein teammate von vorhin vielleicht bist du
gar nicht also ja doch du bist alles klar
wandern war so noch genug stimmt auch wieder und wingsuit geflogen auch aber
ich muss mich einfach mal ein bisschen an der frischen luft bewegen und das ist
morgen morgen früh angesagt aber morgen mittag kommt dann das video ich gucke
jetzt mal schnell ob ich noch jemand hosten hosten kann
oh einer meiner lieblings battlefield stream so spiel 2042 da bin ich mal
gespannt was was der was was er dazu sagt sonst werbung angucken
den gucke ich wirklich gerne spiel hauptsächlich battlefield 3 ich will
wir raiden ihn jetzt mal raiden wir raiden ihn er spielt tatsächlich 2042
nice richtig poc wahrscheinlich im squad oder so sehr definitiv auch mehr
zuschauer verdienen ich gucke wirklich seine battlefield 3 streams ich habe ich
habe den in über die über so highlight videos gefunden und seitdem gucke ich
immer wieder battlefield 3 streams wunderbar aufs nebenbei laufen zu lassen
mich beruhigt battlefield 3 sound im hintergrund
nice facecam nein facecam gibt es nicht ich wurde aber schon oft genug geleakt
also leute dann geht mal rüber spam ein paar emotes wir sehen uns morgen macht es
gut bis denn co betke